okay it's 9:00
a.m. we're going to start off uh
repres that's that's okay do you need to
pledge already on
that um okay representative bone will
pledge if the committee will please
remain standing we're going to have a
moment of silence uh for representative
excuse me uh norren 22 years in the
estate
you welcome back
um this first going to open up the
public hearing for the house election
law committee on cacr 26 this will be a
title read
here relating to election reform and
ballot reconciliation providing that
requirements for elections shall include
provisions and penalties in regard to
ballot reconciliation access retention
polling location limits poll workers all
allowance of registered voters for
post-election ballot viewing ballot lot
and V and Doc voting document viewing
and SC scanning and recording
photographically during citizen audits
okay um the sponsor messaged me last
night um her work because of the snow
that didn't get here um but because of
her work required her to come in so
she's not here to introduce the bill it
is a single sponsor bill so
representative anenberg if you could
please introduce CA cr26 you don't have
to speak to the bill you don't have to
support the bill um you don't have to
take any questions but we do need
someone to formally introduce it um I
don't believe anyone signed up to speak
so I think we're going to get a
25-minute
break thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record uh Aiden anenberg straford 7 um
I'm here to introduce cacr
26 thank you is there anyone signed up
to speak to the bill representative
anenberg can you please send the blue
sheet my way this first one's going to
be real easy you know they said we
weren't going to be able to stay on time
today and here here we are
yep if you can't laugh if you can't
laugh ankor could you pass that blue
sheet when you get a second yeah oh I'm
sorry is it coming oh there it is oh
he's filling out a pink card I'm sorry
I'm sitting here dogging this man and
he's sitting on a pink
card what he just yep I don't make the
rules I just pretend to follow
them okay
uh online there were 32 people signed up
in support and 22 were opposed and I'm
going to go out on a limb and say that
no one was signed in on the blue sheet
uh and with that I will close the public
hearing on cacr 26 and I'll see you guys
9:25
okay going to uh re going to resume the
public hearing of the house election law
committee going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1
085 uh relative to public inspection of
absentee ballot lists uh representative
Hill is here to join US Representative
Hill you're recognized thank you and
welcome to election
law thank you Mr chairman welcome back
to election law I sat in in rep bom's
seat for long
enough
um quick for the record uh I am
representative Greg h Hill I
um represent the town of Northfield
which is marac 2 um I'm here to talk and
introduce House Bill
1085 I've handed you a uh piece of
information um more than anything else
it's just my goal is to try to make sure
that you're aware that this situation
exists um as I sat in that seat that I
mentioned earlier um I used to sit and
try to figure out how would I game the
system if I were um so inclined and this
is an area of concern of mine um and
I've brought this bill before it has
passed the house and then it is uh died
in the Senate so it's back again but
more than anything else I want everyone
sitting here to understand the
information that we've we've worked on
and and what we have with the Secretary
of State's um assistance and blessing um
the bill that you have before us by the
way the uh Secretary of State and I are
working on um actually probably the
deputy secretary Terry and I are working
on some of the language of the questions
that are actually asked at the bottom of
that um there's some um word smithing
that needs to take place there will be
an amendment coming um I think it's at
ol as as we speak but um what you have
in front of you is some work that was
done um on the 2016 election and and
what we started looking at were absentee
ballots that were uh the request for the
absentee ballot was mailed to the
clerks and with no evidence of of ID and
then requested by the clerk to mail it
to a different address than the address
that um the uh voter was registered at
these are only those that were mailed
outside of New Hampshire so the um when
they requested it we didn't the clerk
didn't know who they were um didn't have
positive ID is a better way of saying it
um and mailed the ballot outside of New
Hampshire you'll see from the chart um
because we don't know the specific
address I had asked the Hava people to
at least give us how many of those
ballots that were mailed from New
Hampshire clerks to Common addresses
outside New Hampshire um and what you
see before you is is the the work that
they did they came back and I'll just
pick one two times New Hampshire clerks
in total mailed 21 ballots to the same
physical
address somewhere outside New Hampshire
um the Hava people know what that
address is um the secretary of
state has the information but can't
share it and that's really the purpose
of this bill um so that there is a way
that we're instructing the Secretary of
State to do something either an
investigation phase and Andor hand the
information to the attorney general for
further
investigation that's what that's the
purpose of the
bill there are many reasons why these
can be explained um for example it's
possible those that two times that the
New Hampshire Clark's mailed 21 ballots
to the same physical address it may be
that they went to Brown University or
University of Massachusetts and then
from their Central mailbox it was sent
to a number of different
people that's that's possible it's also
possible that 21 ballots went to one
person at University of um uh
Massachusetts as well we don't know but
but all of these I think demand some
further investigation because it is too
easy because these people these ballots
that are sent or the requests that are
sent to the clerks have no positive ID
it is very possible for someone to
request multiple ballots from um at
least three sources that I've thought of
um I know know and I'm happy to give you
those three sources if if it's of
interest um one of them is college
students one of them is people that they
that they
uh um
telemarket um my mother was getting
phone call after phone call during the
election saying do you plan and the
first question was do you plan to vote
in the next election um they knew she
was on the checklist but if she said no
I don't plan to vote in the next
election
my belief is that can go in a separate
little pile and someone can request her
ballot and she would never go to the uh
town hall and check to see if somebody
had requested her ballot who would um
you know you didn't vote why would you
go and check to see if somebody used
your ballot just never happens
so my point is this is not investigated
this is not not um
reviewed mostly because the information
is just not available um it's in the
database it's just not available without
a court order um so I'm trying to say 60
days after the election this information
should be available um the reason that
I've heard in the past why this is not
available is that it would be too easy
to find out who is not home and then
they would be able to have their homes
burglarized um so I don't really I'm not
married to that 60 days you can make it
180 days you can make it a year I don't
care um the point is these should be
investigated
where physical address where multiple
ballots have gone to a physical address
outside New Hampshire and and when it
happens I don't
care um with that I think I'll end my
testimony happy to answer questions I'm
sure um things have occurred to other
people and and I'm
not um I've said this time and time
again I'm not a smart guy I figured this
out I don't know why um someone that is
much smarter um hasn't figured it out
and taken advantage of how our system is
set up so thanks with that I'll be happy
to answer questions Mr chairman other
questions from the committee
representative
Bay um I think you're a smart guy thank
you Mr chairman um do you have examples
of things like this that uh where they
were actually taken advantage of the
system was taken advantage of um thank
you for your question um no um I I have
no examples um because I don't know who
um I can tell you at the time that we
got this chart and we discussed it with
the Hava people sitting in the archives
um there were examples tossed out not
with specific addresses but they did
point out that one of them and I don't
know which one one of these addresses
happen to be a high rise in Boston in
the financial district
why would multiple ballots be going to a
highrise in in Boston but no one has
ever gone to my knowledge the the next
step and found and gone and knocked on
the door of the high-rise and said why
are you know I don't know 14 uh New
Hampshire ballots coming to your address
I don't know thank you further questions
representative PM
O'Brien okay that's thank you sir um and
I also think you're a smart guy so so
I'm going to ask you some questions
could those do you know if that highrise
was associated with a a university
because if it's a okay no I don't I'm
sorry followup follow
up and also a large military base may
have the
same uh no this this did not include any
U uaba okay okay all right that's but it
may be um just if I can elaborate it may
also be that uh The Villages or some
place like that that um has one central
location where mail is then distributed
within there
are I'm I'm conceding the fact that
these could be legitimate but no one
knows um and the fact that they were
sent to a common address is a should be
a red flag and the fact that um we don't
really know who these people are when
they requested the application for or
when they submitted the application for
the ballot we don't really know who they
are either so th the combination of the
two I think is worthy of
further
viewing representative
weary thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um and obviously uh you've not commuted
into Boston a lot because it might it
that might be a cause for requesting an
absentee ballot but um for these Town
clerks do we you don't have the physical
address that they were mailed to do you
have the distribution of which town
clerks uh no I don't um I don't know if
uh for instance those 14 were mailed
from a single town clerk's um location
or you know if it were me and I were
trying to be
sneaky um I would submit the application
um to a number of different people in
different areas because there's no cross
talk for any of that so um I but I have
no idea okay thank you thank you
representative
wood uh thank you for taking my question
I was just wondering does this imply
that um any of these ballots can go out
to any address so no one's tracking what
addresses um these ballots are going to
or that information is collected we just
can't get to
it um it's almost a distinction without
a difference um I I um I have full faith
and confidence that the information is
that is here is true that the ballots
did go to the same address physically I
I did not see them
perform the actual actual search um I've
only seen this result so I guess it's
um um I I'm not sure really how to
answer the question I I I would say that
there is a there is a a doubt um but
it's not proof positive in any way shape
or form that this is something nefarious
happening yeah can I follow up yep um
fine y yes uh sorry that was a little
confusing but how did he get this data I
mean do they keep track of this and you
you you you got this um I'm just trying
to figure out how how you even know this
so I first went to the Secretary of
State um
and you have to um give me a little bit
of leway because I this is 2016 and I'm
having a hard time figuring out last
week so um this uh my my first
step that I went to the Secretary of
State and and asked him and he said I
don't have the information and at that
time we had to talk with the Hava people
that did have access to the information
to do the um the Sorting the uh the
request of the of this
database um I subsequently I have found
out that the Secretary of State really
does have access to this but can't share
it and can't um manipulate it um for the
purpose of generating this himself um I
think that's true still um but the
information does exist of what what that
address is um and that's what I would
suspect when the amendment not suspect
but that's the amendment that's coming
is going to take this to the next step
and have that information that the
Secretary of State puts together be able
to go to the attorney general for
further investigation if he feels it
warrants that representative
Howard thank you for taking my question
so uh currently is the SOS sending any
potential information over to the
attorney general if there is any
suspected
fraud uh thank you for your question no
because they're not there's no reason he
has no authority to do that there he
can't share that information that's in
the database is what I got from the
Secretary of State thank you you're
welcome representative
Bay thank you Mr chair um please uh let
me tell the spirit of my question I
actually tried to um get
um an absentee B for my daughter who
goes to college in another state far
away from here and I was told okay
either you make uh give this to your
daughter sign the form send it back to
us and so forth and I'm imagining when
they get it they'll check if uh my
daughter's in the voting uh list and and
send it so I my question is what do you
really mean when you say we don't really
know who they are okay so let's say that
that application is sitting on your um
daughter's or this young girl's um desk
at college and and someone asks her um
are you going oh you going to vote are
you going to send that in and she said
no I decided I'm going to um vote here
I'm going to register here in whatever
state she
is that application um there's no reason
why her roommate or anyone couldn't take
that and fill it in with her her
name and mail it and have the have the
clerk send it anywhere else in the in
the well in the country I don't think
you could send it in the world but you
could send it and and she would never
know that she's voted in two
places
which if I was a college student would
worry me if I was on a on a checklist
here in New Hampshire but then decided
to register and vote somewhere else it
would worry me that there's the
possibility that someone ask for my
ballot back here and that's true of any
any of their graduates from UNH or
anywhere else after they graduate it's
very easy to get a list of of who
graduated and who was an out of state
student they typically leave um New
Hampshire and and head somewhere else to
a job it would be no problem to apply
for that um for that uh person's
absentee ballot um easily follow up Mr
follow so uh so this uh procedures right
now where when when you make a request
you have to uh sign the form right so
that's that's basically uh in your
opinion is really not working so um I
believe the and I'm sure the chair can
correct me um my understanding was um
signatures are not acceptable to be
compared so they couldn't compare it to
this young girl and say that doesn't
look like your signature I don't think
it uh signature would be the catch for
this thank you that is correct the court
said that if we are to conduct signature
verification we have to provide
handwriting analysis training so that's
not happening uh further questions uh I
have one quick question why did you
limit it to addresses outside of New
Hampshire why what if there's 50 going
to an address in New Hampshire uh it
it's entirely possible um at the time we
were we were trying to um when I
mentioned it to the Secretary of State I
said um what would be a manageable
number for them to do since this was
kind of a fishing Expedition at the time
um but he did point out and I think
somewhere on this um handout that I
given you is the is the suggestion that
the secretary of state was going to go
back and ask specifically for common
addresses within New Hampshire as well
um it it there's you're perfectly
correct that there this could obviously
be happening within New Hampshire um as
well as out of New Hampshire okay
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
Hill thank
you uh only one of the only one of the
pink car in possessions deputy secretary
Hennessy and represent in could you
sheet good morning everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state I
spoke with representative Hill about
this bill recently um at the time he
collected his data I was sitting next to
him in the house of Representatives so I
was not involved in his original data
collection um but I am happy to take
answer uh take questions on this and
give you just a little feedback I did
request some language changing just to
change requests to application um and
also um suggest that um once he gets the
data what what is it that should be done
with the data typically when we get
requests for this type of information or
requirements in law um we have to share
with the chair of the house election law
committee the senate election law
committee the speaker the House of
Representatives and the Attorney
General's office and then requ and then
the law would require them to
investigate so um some additional
language would be needed to um require
um the sharing and the investigation
piece of it but I believe he's working
on amendment to that questions from the
committee representative
Hamlet thank you Mr chairman thank you
um Deputy sec secr AR um so I should
know this question I should know the
answer to this question does the
absentee ballot
application require an
ID thank you for the question no it does
not okay all
right further questions from the
committee representative
Howard so uh is there are there any
opportunity uh thank you for taking my
question sorry are there any
opportunities uh for the Secretary of
State's office to contact the Attorney
General's office if there are any
inconsistencies thank you for the
question representative Howard I um in
listening to representative Hill's
testimony I came up with an example
where if um if a town clerk were to um
witnessed some suspicious activity say
she um processed 21 applications for one
address and she lives next to that
address and knows that 21 people don't
live there then we if and she contacted
our off office we would refer her to the
AG's office and then they would do some
investigation but as far as doing data
analysis in our office and giving that
information to the AG's office we don't
do that currently okay thank you further
questions from the committee represent
weing uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um offand uh
since these are out of state data do we
know anything about the instate data
with regard to
this thank you for the question I have
not not um done any data analysis or
requested any data analysis since I've
been in the
office further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh
Deputy secret almost colge
representative Hennessy deputy secretary
say Hennessy um oh yes R do you have a
question I'm sorry actually not for um
the deputy secretary down and I hate to
do this but could we have representative
hill come back I have a question for him
okay thank you if he's willing I don't
no I'm sorry I'm sorry I've only had
half a cup of coffee so you know um I
was just curious why the Senate didn't
act on it and were you aware did they
express their concerns when you took the
bill over there uh thank you for the
question it's an excellent one um so one
time um that this was brought up I think
it and I'm scratching my memory here
without coffee um my understanding was
it was one of those it was a year that
we uh a number of bills ended up dying
on the table
um I think it was during the the yeah um
yeah I think it was during the shorten
year
um yeah um correct so that that's my
recollection um such as it
is yeah I don't think it was based on
the me on the the merits of the bill
yeah there you go yeah I have had I
don't I haven't had my CL but I've had
my My Monster Energy to drink um okay
any other questions representative hill
before we uh let him go off and do uh
his thing all right thank you so much
and look at that it's 950 so we'll close
the public hearing on House Bill
1085 signed up to speak I mean sorry um
there's no one signed up to speak on the
blue sheet that didn't speak and one on
the sheet uh online there were 29 in
support 20 opposed and I'm going to
close the public hearing uh going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
1092 creating a period for the placing
of and removal of political advertising
on public property going to recognize
our own representative Howard for the
purpos of introduction of the Bill thank
you so much Mr chair and uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the District of straford 4 uh so I have
actually passed out an amendment already
for this bill uh to kind of allow for
two options uh for the committee to
consider uh I prefer the amended version
myself but essentially uh this would
clarify the rules of when we would be
allowed to post signage on public
property uh so a as we uh know when we
sign up to become Representatives we are
of course putting our names out into the
public and we also have cleanup dates
for those signs uh a week after the
election uh you know unless it's the
primary then we have uh another week uh
uh we'll have extended periods if we win
uh till the general but the thing is is
that as we know uh and part of the
reason why I've uh gone and submitted
this legislation is because the town of
barington one of the towns that I
represent uh has requested this language
uh due to the fact that we had a
candidate for select board who was
posting signage before the November
election uh in 2022 uh of course when
you're running for a position that is up
in March there's a little bit of voter
confusion that can happen uh in that
type of situation so I've of course was
receiving a number of questions about
this candidate and if we were going to
be having Town elections before uh March
and of course that was something where
it kind of caused a bit of a stir in the
community so this would at least kind of
clarify when we could put the signage
out in the amended version it would be
after uh the filing period uh which I
think is very fair and uh very
reasonable uh so with that being said
I'm open to any questions are there
questions from the
committee um I actually do have
questions because I'm familiar with this
case that you're referring to um just so
if if another member wants to jump in on
this by the way because I'm just going
to kind of run here for a second but if
someone want to jump in let me know I
don't want to monopolize it um so this
case this is the guy running for
Selectmen he owns a gun store right or
something like that um and he's posting
a 4x8 if I recall 4 foot by8 foot sign
um on his property but it's in the
public right of way but it is on his
property MH right um so you know this I
hate I hate I loathe the slippery slope
argument because it's so you can use it
for anything but you know if it's his
property and he's posting a sign posting
any political sign for me it doesn't
matter that he's a candidate he's
posting any political sign it could say
representative Barry is is a jerk
um yeah don't Vote Barry for governor um
how yeah I I I get like you know the
roundabouts the or if it's obstructing
public view right it's a safety hazard
like all of I I get I get true what I
would call truly public space and I get
safety concerns right but this sign my
understanding is it's it's back off of
it's not like on the road um but they
just don't like that it's up so early
but he does have a First Amendment right
to express his political opinion even if
it's obnoxiously a year before his
election how who are we I guess to get
to my question who are we to C curtail
his first amendment right on property
that he does own there's a public right
away but he owns that property um so if
it's not creating a safety concern it's
not it's his property who are we to tell
him what he can post specifically about
political speech on his property yeah so
uh yeah I mean I'm I'm fine with
whatever he wants to put up on his own
private property uh but the thing is is
that there were more than just the 4x8
there were the uh the uh the corrugated
plastic uh signs that you know we buy in
bulk and those were all up and down
Route 125 and uh and in route n and uh
the thing is is that that was kind of
the concern that I had was the fact that
these are all in public spaces on right
of ways uh outside of the private
property that he owns I understand that
there is some discomfort with that sign
but uh as long as you know it's again
following all of the safety guidelines
and is posted on private property I I
don't have a concern with that the thing
is is with and that's why I specify
ified public spaces uh on the bill uh so
that it would be kind of uh a little bit
clearer uh to kind of say if it's not
private uh but it's the public property
the you know uh the the intersections uh
and roundabouts as you mentioned that
would be kind of more concern to me uh
and concern to the voters as again they
were all over town okay so I'm so so
your intention is not the I'm talking
about where it's on his right it's on
the RightWay but it's not obstructing
and it's his property so we're not
talking about that we're talking about
the roundabouts the town squares right
we're talking about truly public
property okay all right so that I'm much
more comfortable with um sorry I I
wanted to get I wanted to get that
clarified representative Wei yeah thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question is is there a legal definition
for public Space versus private
property um that I am not uh aware of I
tried to kind of make it as
uh well not necessarily as broad as
possible but uh to specify the fact that
we're focusing on public spaces and not
private property so I mean I can try and
work on something to uh get a better
answer for you uh followup yeah yeah I'm
just
uh as it's written could there be
concerns about
someone um you know declaring well I can
see it it's in public space and even
though it might be on private property
or that sort of thing starting to try to
enforce this using that as a mechanism
where there's potentially a
conflict you know with the private
property uh allowances and and
so what are your thoughts on on that um
well I I I think that in terms of the
way that we've uh been kind of trying to
approach it there is legislative intent
and we can kind of make the argument
that this is intended for specifically
public spaces uh as we've already
discussed here you know uh right of way
public right of ways roundabouts
Etc Y where yes
followup so uh just you know in in uh
Hudson for example if someone if someone
were to do this the Public Works would
come by if it was on uh you know public
property as it were
um Public Works would come by they'd
sweep them up if the person wanted them
they'd pick them up at you know the Town
Center um uh and you know could repost
them again if they wanted to and then
they would you know get picked up again
um so I
guess is does bearing not have this
capacity to pick these up or is is it
just because it was on private property
and so they weren't allowed to I'm just
trying to understand the well I think
they wanted to clarify the rules a bit a
little bit because as I had said these
signs uh were up and down Route
125 uh and Route 9 and uh they were in
public spaces not on private property
and so uh they they were not uh
necessarily Pi having those picked up
uh so they were staying out in public
spaces which is part of the reason why
they requested this
legislation further
questions um yes representative query
quae excuse me wow representative quy
representative the guy that I beat in my
race why we really went into a aware of
there yes representative qua and thank
you Mr chairman for that thorough
introduction and and thank you
representative Howard for taking my
question um I'm just reading here
66417 and it states
explicitly no political advertising
shall be placed on or fixed to any
public
property including Highway rights of way
or private property without the owner's
consent does that suggest at all that
the means already exist in the law for
for say a municipality where someone has
posted signage on the municipal property
already has the authority to not Grant
permission and require it to be removed
so thank you yeah this this is that part
of the statement that's basically saying
that we as candidates cannot Place
signage wherever we would like on even
uh private rways like if you put it in
front of somebody's home without asking
them first and without their
consent uh followup and wouldn't that
imply that municipalities you actually
own some public proper property for
example would would have the authority
to refuse permission to put a sign of
any sort on that property already
wouldn't that already have that
Authority thank you I I don't know
because the way the way that I've read
that it's it's mostly to kind of give
Property Owners uh a little bit further
uh uh rights over the land that they are
owning is if you're putting out on
something that may be public but right
in front of their home it may look like
they are supporting you uh in your race
but they may be supporting a different
candidate for instance and so this would
kind of allow them to uh remove that
signage uh legally
speaking okay thank you representative
B thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question um the law currently
States political advertising placed on
or fixed to any public property may be
removed by state city or town
maintenance or law enforcement Personnel
isn't that already in
law um well I I think that this is to
kind of uh further that statement and
kind of because there are certain
opportunities where towns do take
liberties with what is allowed and what
is acceptable of postage of political
signage in public spaces and this would
kind of create a uh a an area where they
could kind of say this is our start
period you just can't place it after or
I mean before this point uh and after
people have filed for their election and
freely um any other questions
representative Burnham thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question do you think perhaps it might
be a little confusing to have the words
public spaces in one portion in the
second part public property perhaps if
it's adjusted as public property that
might be a little more clear yeah I mean
I I would be open to amending that uh
further and um we we can definitely work
on that together um I mean as I stated
the reason I wanted to clarify public
versus private is that I didn't want to
restrict people's ability to uh voice
their First Amendment right on private
property so thank you further questions
representative
wood thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question now you're proposing
two different versions uh one showing it
60 days before the election and one
after the filing period yeah so have any
comments along the way of where you yeah
reset thanks so yeah sorry I I have had
a number of conversations with other
groups where they cancern they had
concerns over the 60-day period uh and I
I have to agree with them I prefer the
in day version of the bill uh because
that makes it very clear that once you
are a candidate uh then you can post uh
the political signage but if you are not
necessarily declaring that
beforehand uh then it kind of creates a
start period I mean we as as I stated we
already have a cleanup period uh where
we're supposed to clean up these signs
and this kind of just creates an end gap
on the other side where it says I'm
starting uh and I can then go and
publicly post uh signage in uh in these
spaces that are
allowed further questions from the Comm
Bay thank you Mr chair okay this is
probably nitpicky so if I for this one
if there's a 10-day filing period a
candidate can only put a sign after the
filing period would you
uh welcome an amendment that'll say
after the first day of the file fing
period or after the the candidate
actually filed yeah I I'd be I'd be open
to that thank you okay uh further
questions seeing n thank you
representative Howard only have one
other pink card in my possessions deputy
Hennessee good morning everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state
um
the um as the chair of the committee
pointed out the political advertising on
on private property is free speech um
and to representative uh Burnham's point
the public spaces as defined in here
isn't very well defined
um back in I believe the 90s a similar
law was in place and I do not know the
details behind that but I would
recommend reaching out to OS or
legislative research to find out why
that law was taken off the books um I
think based on conversations with other
people there may have been a lawsuit and
so they legis the legislature at that
time took it off the books um I and
again I don't know the details but I
would recommend just reaching out to
legislative research to find out the
history of this section um also better
defining what public space means does it
mean that if I have a huge bumper
sticker that I keep on my vehicle for a
candidate that ran for election eight
years ago am I not allowed to park in a
public parking spot um does it mean that
um I as an individual property owner own
the land along the highway that you
spoke of and I'm sorry I don't know the
instance of that you're speaking of but
I own that actual land and the state has
a RightWay through that land um and I've
given an individual candidate right to
post signs all year round on my land
even though the state has a right away
there are they not allowed to do that um
so just some clarification about what
public spaces means um and what um
anything that would be able to help
better Define for our office what what
the intent is and also I imagine I can't
speak for the AG's office but how to
investigate
it will you be taking questions I would
love to take questions I might not have
the answers though questions from the
committee representative PR bran thank
you and thank you for being here uh
would you believe that that instance
that sounded a little far-fetched truly
happened to me in my community many
years ago where I was asked to move my
vehicle because I had a it was on
yeah it's like a it's like a it's like a
sure it's like a sure sure um well move
on next question for repres for jeez
deputy secretary of state Hennessy I'm
I'm wow I'm batting a thousand today all
right uh saying none thank you um I
don't have any other pink cards in my
possession representative anenberg can
you pass that blue sheet
over um signed up online were 29 in
support zero oppose zero
it uh
Pro and then one one person signed up
who didn't speak in support with that
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 1092 and we will stand in
recess until 10:15 for the purposes of
okay we're back oh W um send this ship
this um going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill
1099 relative to partisan School
District elections um going to repres
recognize representative power for the
purpose of introduction is that that's
down thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill
1099 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville in
Hillsboro County District
36 to begin this bill was filed upon the
request of a number of my constituents
this is a simple straightforward Bill
the purpose of this bill is to allow for
partisan School District elections House
Bill 1099 is enabling legislation which
means that the legislative body the
voters of a school district may choose
to adopt the provisions or not and they
also may choose to resend the provisions
once adopted currently there is enabling
statute to allow for partisan Town
elections under RSA 6691 12 therefore it
only makes sense that we would allow for
partisan School District
elections now allow me to briefly
explain the provisions of this bill keep
in in mind that the provisions in this
bill before you mirror and also
reference the provisions for partisan
Town
elections as I mentioned in RSA
669 if this enabling legislation statute
is adopted then partisan nominations for
school district elections shall be
available to any political party which
pulled at least 3% of the entire vote
cast for the office of governor in the
last election
currently in New Hampshire that would
include two parties Democrat and
Republican partisan nominations for
school district offices are made using a
caucus system by a secret ballot and
then put forward by the Democrat and
Republican Town committees in which the
school district is
located with this bill persons wishing
to to to seeking to run for a school
district office have three options to
get their name on the
ballot option one a person can file
their name for an open school district
office with the clerk of the Town
political committee the town political
committee then meets in caucus to vote
and select their party nominees for the
various open
offices and then the town committee
would then notify the school district
clerk of their part an nominees so these
people that went through this process
they would be partisan nominees option
two a person can alternatively collect
50 what is called nomination papers for
a particular school district office from
the voters of their political party
within the school district the person
would then present the required number
of nomination papers to the school
district clerk this person then becomes
a partisan
nominee and then option three is a
person who does not wish to seek any
partisan affiliation they simply would
file with the town clerk or the school
district clerk using the same process
today this person then becomes an
unaffiliated nominee so additional
details to note with regards to this
bill the caucuses for selecting partisan
Nomine must be held before the
sixth Friday before the school district
election the caucus selection process is
outlined in RSA 669 colon 18 and RSA 669
col 37- 53 and it speaks to notice
location checklists ballots hours and
the filing certificates of nomination
each Town political committee can
nominate one candidate for each open
Office position in the school district
with regards to ballots uh what the
ballot will look like it would have
three columns listing the candidates for
each office Republican Democrat and
other and this is similar to the ballot
for the partisan state general elections
that were all familiar with and um also
notably The Ordering of the columns and
the candidates would be determined
annually by a random draw by the
Secretary of State lastly they I have an
amendment which I passed out to the bill
and this um relates to the process for
partisan scho School District elections
when um a co-op is involved I forgot to
address that when I drafted this bill in
the summer um and then filed the bill in
September so the amendment simply
outlines that political Town Committees
of the towns in the co-op they would
combine their votes for their partisan
nominee for at large positions um like
the moderator the clerk or the the the
School District Treasurer in conclusion
House Bill 1099 is enabling legislation
that provides a formal Avenue for major
political parties to identify and select
candidates and this bill allows for a
candidate who so desires to be clearly
identified with a major political party
on the ballot for school district
elections I respectfully ask that this
committee please recommend otpa on House
Bill 1099 to Pro to to provide school
districts with the option for partisan
elections thank you Mr chairman that
concludes my bill introduction and I'm
checking the time because I have to
introduce another bill and another
committee but I see that I have some
time to answer some questions okay what
is your cut off just for my for time um
I'd say probably quarter of okay perfect
representative
B thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question so is this bill The
Identical procedure to what is existing
a law now for Town partisan elections
thank you for the question
representative that is correct um as I
said that currently in New Hampshire we
have that ability and a number of
constituents said why don't we have this
um uh enabling legislation for for
school district elections so yes thank
you further questions from committe
Hamlet thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um
so in our municipal elections and in
school school uh par in School elections
we
already uh it's already possible for
anybody of any party or non-party
to um file to be a candidate correct so
what is the advantage to having the the
parties choose their candidate thank you
for the question representative so the
the premise of this bill is to allow for
the the party um affiliation to be um
denoted on the ballot as we do in the
general
election further questions on the
committee representative P
O'Brien thank you and thank you for
taking my
question what reasons have you heard
from your constituents who say they want
this what how would this help them you
thank you for the question
representative so um what has been
communicated and explain to me is is
that they would like that they see that
as additional information to inform them
and in making their um selection when
when voting for these particular
offices representative
Bay thank you Mr chair um with um to to
your knowledge how many towns have
adopted partisan
elections thank you for the question
representative So based on my research
with regards to the enabling statute
that we have right now pertaining to
town elections I am not aware of any
towns based on my research however I am
aware of a number of towns that have
attempted to pass this enabling
legislation and they've the constituents
have done done so through a petitioned
warrant article that being said I am
aware of the city of Portsmouth they do
have Municipal um partisan Municipal
elections for what is called their
election officials I did speak to the to
the to the clerk of the city of
Portsmouth and so that they that would
be an example of a municipality in New
Hampshire that does in fact have
partisan Municipal
elections further questions from the
committee representative Brennan thank
you thank you for taking my question um
we're living in a very very divisive
time with um extremes and it
causes challenges even at the local
level and I'm wondering if you have any
concerns about this bill contributing to
more division at the local level um
because you would be taking something
that is nonpartisan and serving the
entire community and making it into
partisan um election do you have any
concerns about that thank you for the
question representative that's an
interesting questions question and um to
be clear you know politics whether you
know you wear a label or not it it is
partisan and you know people based on
their their views and what they bring to
the table to the elected positions and
how they vote it is partis so I don't
see this as anything that's going to
contribute to what is our already um a
reality with regards to um government in
our state representative
B thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking another question uh but even
somebody is a Democrat or Republican
they can still sign up as other correct
thank you for the question
representative that is correct as I
explained there's three options and
three ways to get on the ballot two
options you you would be a partisan
nominee and the third one is that yes
correct you can choose not to to to
pursue a partisan um nomination and just
sign up as the process is today so that
is correct thank you representative
Lane I I think representative bone
addressed my question thank
you turn my own mic off representative
rafter um yeah thank you Mr chair thanks
for taking my question um did you say
earlier that if you wanted to be an
independent you would have to get 50
signatures to be on the ballot and is
that a bit of a hurdle for people thank
you for the question representative so
that so I explained an option two if um
a person seeking a school district
office didn't want to go through the
caucus um process to become a partisan
nominee they could um alternatively get
it's signatures it's called nomination
papers of 50 and um to be
clear this bill is modeled exactly after
the process for me you know partisan
Town elections so I'm not doing anything
different or above and beyond I feel
that it's it's important to keep things
um consistent across the board thank you
all right uh representative weie since
the Comm I am going to end questioning
for representative power at 10:30 to
keep us on time representative we uh
just a quick logistical question
question if I may thank you Mr chair
just a quick logistical question um
amend the bill your Amendment says amend
the bill after replacing all of section
one so this part in the original Bill
stays intact and then everything
following it would be replaced by the
amendment I just want to make sure that
is correct yes that's correct okay thank
you all right one more question for
representative power um representative
Brennan just I I I just want
clarification if that's okay um did you
say that there are zero municipalities
who that have chosen to enable partisan
elections aside from um the city of
Portsmith there are zero towns that have
enabled that thank you for the question
representative I have not had much
success with the research Department
here in um that's availed to us so I did
my own research on my own time and I was
unable to find any so that doesn't mean
that they're not out there but I would
emphasize the point that this is
enabling legislation it's a tool in our
toolbox and if School dist well in this
case if School District or altern you
know if a town would like to um and the
voters in that town would like to have
this as an option it's there yes okay
with that we'll let representative power
go um thank you next up will be Eric
power
[Music]
good morning honorable members of the
election law committee my name is Eric
power I'm from the town of
Brookline I'm also the president of an
organization called the school district
governance Association of New Hampshire
and also I serve as the Secretary of our
Brookline Mason uh Republican
committee and I'd like to speak in favor
of this bill um I think it's an it's an
important bill um to allow voters to be
able to have a partisan election for the
school district like we can for the town
um I think it gives the voters more
information and um our town committee
would be eager to do that you know if
you look at the legislation as proposed
uh as the I would be the clerk that
would be running the caucus that would
help select the school district
nominees um this is uh a common sense
bill that allows the voters to have more
information and also allows the the
Committees in the town to be able to be
more active in the town elections and in
this case the school district
elections the uh this year we in
Brookline we have a worn article to
adopt the municipal Town elections we
have not put that forth previously so we
have that going and we did it by
petition and uh as part of that when I
was getting signatures and talking to
people said why can't we do this for the
school district District too we really
would like to do that and so logically
it said well we can't quite do it yet
the legislature hasn't permitted it for
us so there's clearly um a need and a
and a want for some folks to have that
just to be clear so if you did it in a
school district you would all your
school district officials could be
nominated and elected on a partisan
basis the the most common you would
think of would be the school board if
you had a Cooperative School District it
would be your school board and if you
had a Cooperative budget committee they
would also be under that as well as your
other
officers the um the other thing that may
not be clear exactly um you're all state
representatives and I know that
sometimes the Republicans caucus and the
democrat's caucus that's available to
you under 91a because you were elected
on a partisan
basis so if you have a school board that
is elected or a Cooperative budget
committee that's elected on a part basis
they could also have a partisan caucus
the same way you have a partisan caucus
here in the uh in the state house as
Republicans and Democrats so that's
another very powerful tool that becomes
part of this if you uh if if it's
adopted by the school
district um I would say that this is
this is enabling legislation so it's
just available if You' like it or not if
the voters want it they can vote for it
if the voters don't want it they don't
they can resend it if they don't see it
working for them and I think that you
know we we live sort of in a world where
there is politics whether you like to
admit it or not and so this just allows
the the voters with more information
about who they're voting for and I think
it it makes a lot of
sense so with that I will close thank
you will you be taking questions from
the committee yes I will all right are
there questions from the committee
representative PR
O'Brien I thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman do you
think this would increase voter
participation in those notoriously vot
loer low voter turnout elections uh on
the school and town level what do you
think that's a great question
representative thank you for the
question the I think it will increase
voter engagement because they'll see
they'll see the partisan piece of it in
there whether you're an independent or
you're a republican you're a Democrat we
are I don't know about most towns but in
our town we range anywhere from 15 to
25% turnout it's often below
20% and I think it just would engage
more voters there's a lot of apathy out
there and this is a tool that was that
was the main reason we actually have put
forth the article for adopting the
partisan elections for our town this
year um I know that there was another
attempt at um adopting partisan
elections that did not pass that was in
Atkinson in
2022 so there there is a there 's a
desire and I think that folks are like
well if why can't we have partisan
ballots for for the school and the town
so I think it would make sense and I
think that there might even be more
interest in it if you could do it that
way and that would increase voter
turnout I believe thank
you further questions representative
Brennan thank you um just going back to
your testimony about enabling uh
caucusing among school board members so
you my school board has five members
let's say three of them were Republicans
and two of them were Democrats would it
not create a situation where you have
isolated members of the school board uh
say if it was 4 to
one would it wouldn't it create a
situation
where you are not encouraging working
together thank you for the question I
think it's the same you would ask the
same question question does that does
being partisan here in this committee
offer the
same get working together or not I think
I think it's it's a valuable tool and I
think it you know elections have
consequences and who's on the board um
makes a difference and who the caucuses
are and I think the caucuses are you
know the way it works is you take a
temporary break and then you come back
so I think it it leads it it it helps
people work together I think by
caucusing together I think that you can
arrive at compromises a little bit more
because you can in a private caucus I
can talk to fellow Republicans and
decide what's the right way ahead how
can we compromise I think it would
increase cooperation followup please
we're go representative Lane unless she
wants to
yield y rep yes representative
Brennan thank you um if this is a way
that we were going to this was a road we
were going to take would you support
requiring students to register with a
political party as well so that they
would would know um that they have
representation on their school
board I don't see that that's relevant
to this question I I I served I didn't
mention this but I served as a
Cooperative School Board member for
three years and I think that if if
students are old enough they should go
register to vote but I think you know
and they they would know who the
partisan candidates are if they're if
they're
voting further questions representative
Lane
um thank you U Mr chair I have a similar
followup to representative Brennan and
what representative bone was talking
about to the previous um
witness are you aware that over onethird
of the voters in New Hampshire are
other I I am aware of the statistics
about the Republican Party having a
slight Edge over the Democrats currently
in New Hampshire and then um um with
Independence being the biggest block yes
I am so that but there's still a path
for people to be independent you know
the the ballot would have Republicans
and Democrats and other so there's this
is just enabling if you want to be part
of the partisan process you can but
you're not forced to further
questions representative Bay thank you
Mr chair with regard to um uh partisan
elections identifying the parties as um
just additional information on the
candidates do you know of anything
that's uh precluding um candidate in a
nonpartisan election uh to identify
their party affiliation in their uh
materials that they distribute in their
campaign thank you representative there
is nothing that prohibits it in the
campaign materials the signs and such
and some do and I did um but uh but
having it actually on the ballot
this is really um something that voters
would like to know because not everybody
sees all the advertising that's out
there it's always hard to reach voters
so like I said more information is
better for those who want
it okay further questions see um okay
well we're going to we're going to keep
things going along we'll have one more
question then we're going to bring up
the next
speaker yeah so would would this uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so would this so say in uh
town I I from the green party and I
wanted to register to vote is there any
mechanism that would allow me to say
that I was from the green party and
wanted to you know uh participate in the
ballot in that with that sort of
affiliation is is it so that even if I
was separate from the caucuses I would
still be able to
identify if you will my political
leanings by that party
affiliation thank you for the question
under today's law with the with the uh
partisan Town elections it's only
available to those parties that received
3% or more in the previous election for
governor so if the green party did have
3% they could uh have a caucus and they
could nominate someone but that's the
way the law is for uh Municipal Town
elections for partisan so that's the
same same thing that we're following for
the uh School District okay thank you so
much uh we're going to let you go
um next up is Barrett Christina from the
New Hampshire School Board Association
the last pink card that I have R vber if
you start shipping me the blue sheet
excellent never mind it's already in my
possession thank you thank you chairman
Barry thank you members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Barrett
Christina I am the executive director of
the New Hampshire school boards
Association we are not taking a position
on this bill primarily because it's
enabling um um and and and when there's
enabling bills we often don't take
positions with them however I do want to
just highlight um a couple issues with
the bill and sort of the larger policy
issues and perhaps answer a couple
questions um that that have been asked
where there may be some some some CL
some some confusion or or some answer
still may be needed um first of all it
it's hard enough to find people to run
for local elections these days whether
or not a school board um a select board
uh your school district uh clerk your
school district moderator NH hsba would
have a concern that identifying these as
partisan positions would only lessen the
pool of people who are who are willing
and able to run for locally elected
office um second of all from a school
district perspective um the first aspect
of good Schoolboard governance is
students not party affiliation or or
partis in
politics um second um I guess somewhat
related how would this bill I know this
isn't the purview of this committee I
understand that but how would this bill
help students nhba views everything
relative to school districts whether
it's elections or the delivery of
services is that how it impacts and how
it helps
students um continuing um a typical
Schoolboard member I know we have a
couple former school board members on on
on this committee as it as it as it is
um but in my experience your typical
Schoolboard parent is is a soccer mom or
a soccer dad who's just trying to be be
maintain an interest in their child's
School help out where they can provide
the voice of other parents within the
district it it's not about being a
Republican or a Democrat or an
party um in terms of gathering
information um about a particular
candidate's um positions or views many
many candidates will have a Facebook
page Joe Smith for conquered School
Board um many school boards will have
you meet the candidates night before
March election where they'll come in and
and the members of the public may have
an opportunity to interview and ask
candidates their particular views on
school funding or books in the library
or the building project or whatever it
might be um we also have concerns as how
this might impact employees um if a
school board um is of one particular
party or another um and uh through um
School through teachers union work um
are are teachers going to be targeted
for positions that they're taking in
their private time that may not be
popular with the with the with the the
majority of of their elected School
Board um also um we would have concerns
that policies and programming would
swing back and forth every March if our
par if our School Board elections um
became partisan um you know things like
uh curriculum
and and and and textbooks and computer
programs those are those are expensive
and we don't want one side picking this
one election and the other side picking
this a following election um to some of
the other questions that were raised um
I I did not know that this was T that
the primary language was lifted from uh
similar Provisions in RSA 669 until
representative power mentioned that um
that statute was enacted in
1979 um I did do um I I sent a text to
my colleagues at the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and asked if any
uh towns um have implemented the
provisions of of um uh RSA 669 col 12
the answer was none so 45 years later no
municipalities have chosen to enact the
municipal uh I'm sorry the partisan
election system um and relative to that
um you
know speaker before me said that there's
there's politics you know in in in our
schools whether we like it or not well
whether we like it or not shouldn't
necessarily be um the question um if we
don't like it I'm not sure that adding
more politics into um our Public School
uh discussions and decisions is going to
help alleviate partisanship whether or
not that's on the local level the state
level or the national level so um I
think that's it um uh the other one
practical Point um uh we talked about
sort of the election the the
pre-election system for getting on the
ballot um and and currently if go to the
town clerk or the school district clerks
you fill out a form you pay your $10 and
you're on the ballot now we're talking
about having a a republican caucus and
delegates just just just to get on the
ballot it seems like we're inserting a
an unnecessarily difficult process um to
to to to to achieve what we don't think
necessarily has a great outcome anyway
anyway so thank you for your time Mr
chair thank you for your time committee
I'm happy to answer any questions
questions from the committee
representative P Brian thank you sir uh
you mentioned that textbooks and
software are expensive and you wouldn't
want one person one side picking that
but if one side was ending up to pick
those things wouldn't it be reflective
of the will of the populace of the will
of the voters thank you very much
question yeah well it it it would
certainly be reflective of the will of
election questions on the committee
further questions um I do have one um so
these uh Town elections School Board
elections the same day um the
notoriously low turnout which if you
ever follow this committee you know has
been a huge um sticking point for me one
of the reasons they are low turnout is
because voters do not know who the
candidates are one of the reasons we
have party preference is because it
gives you kind of a boilerplate of who
that candidate aligns with so wouldn't
this bill one of there there's negative
effects there's positive effects but
wouldn't one of the positive effects be
that we could actually see increased
turnout in these elections um because
voters would know by default going in
which which candidates align with their
particular Viewpoint sure thank you very
much for the question and that's
certainly a reasonable um take on on on
why we might want to do this I think
there may be other reasons though why
voter turn out in local elections is is
less than it is when we having election
general elections in November when
you're when you're voting for your for
your your school board there may be one
person on the belt or one seat on the
Belt when we're going to a general
election in November there may be
president Senators House of
Representatives some State elections so
on and so forth so to your point yes I I
think that's a valid point but I don't
know if that's necess neily the entire
reason
why as a we'll end here we'll end you
with there I don't see any other
questions I will remark with this your
school's taxes are the largest portion
of your tax bill so just on a personal
level I have trouble accepting that
argument I think it's because they don't
know who the the candidates are but
thank you so much that's my little
that's my little pardon gift to you
there's no one else um to speak um so
with that we'll close the public hearing
um online it was 31 in support uh three
oppose zero neutral I'm going to yield
the chair uh to represent Vice chairman
bill opening up the public hearing on
House Bill 1126
and we're hear from representative Barry
who is the Prime sponsor of the Bill
thank you Mr chairman um this is a
follow-up piece of legislation to what
we passed I believe it was bipartisan uh
last year um this has been one of those
things that I've been getting at now I
guess for four years now um about making
these absentee ballot lists more
accessible and available to candidates
so to give you guys kind of the history
here um a bill we passed passed I
believe it was I want to say it was the
first session of my first so I want to
say in 2021 uh we passed a bill that
gave candidates the right to have
electronic access to the absentee ballot
list requests um so in that language it
said that you as a candidate could
basically email your town clerk but
saying Hey I want to get the list of
people who requested absentee ballots
one of the shortcuts we did there was we
used existing RSA referencing the um
election database the election like
portal um and it turns out that there
are limitations to what you can get out
of that already defined in the statute
we referenced uh so specifically the
information that you were legally
allowed to get was the voter name the
voter adid number the date the ABS
ballot was requested and the date the
ABS ballot was returned um so that's
great for people like me who are able to
create relational databases and take the
voter ID number use it as has a um it's
called a reference key and then tag it
to the voter file then spit out the
address um so if you know how to do that
life's great if you don't know how to do
that the list is worthless um so what
I'm doing here is I'm adding that you
get the address where registered so not
the address where it's mailed we heard
that and I know that that's going to be
a debate but the address where the
voter's registered uh the voter's party
affiliation um the type of the election
the ballot was cast in and I'll talk
about that in a second and the date it
was mailed so right now you get the date
that it was requested and the date it
was returned but you'll also get the
date that the clerk sent it out um the
type of the election the ballots cast in
um most a lot of Voters in these um not
the odd year elections but the evene
elections they request their primary
ballot and their um uh general election
ballot in in the same in the same poll
right they'll send in the form so you
need to be able to see as a candidate
which election you're talking about
whether it's the primary or the general
um but I'm hoping it's pretty
non-controversial the information with
the exception of the date it was mailed
the information is already all of this
can be hobbled together um if you have
the right um uh data set skills but um I
don't think it should be limited to just
those that can create relational
databases I think everybody should be
able to to use this to communicate with
their voters and with that I'm happy to
take
questions any questions representative
Lane thank you Mr chair um why is the
both voter ID number needed why is it
needed yeah um well we already get it um
it is a way to identify the individual
voter it's the you know everything
everything stems from that right um so
last names can change right all sort
change but your voter number stays the
same so it's just a way of tracking
tracking people we already get
it yeah it's already the voter ID number
is already public information as well so
it's not that's not like a secret a
secret number thank you representa PR
Brian thank you
is it possible that there could be say
two people with the same name and an
address and that would clear that sort
of thing up you know like a father and
son sort of thing correct cuz sometimes
the Juniors and the seniors gets left
off you really do need the voter ID
number um I mean that that you currently
get it um but you really do need it to
uh create you know distinction in
certain cases I'd say definitely limited
cases representative
warry thank you thank you Mr chair um on
the earlier bill that we heard today
with respect to absente ballots it
mentioned kind of a 60-day period um so
that you know if someone were gone for a
period of
time uh you know Snowbird or that sort
of situation that you wouldn't be making
them subject to vandalism or that sort
of thing or even though this current
regulation doesn't have that would are
you amendable to something like that oh
absolutely not no um so the first thing
is is this is limited to candidates um
it's not a public access list the
candidates already have the rights to it
and it is explicitly for the purposes of
campaigning so when you put a 60-day
delay on it um you make the whole thing
I like if you appr that I would I would
I would go down swinging on it fighting
it it's uh candidates have a right to
know um yeah I I talked about this all
the time candidates have certain rights
to candidates have a right to know who
their voters are um candidates have a
right to campaign to those voters even
if those voters sometimes don't want to
be campaigned to um you know that's the
first amendment stuff but you know if
you are voters who are pulling an
absente ballot you have a very short
window especially in a general election
you have a very short window to get to
them right right now it's like 45 days
so you know you want like I have a very
large seat I you're Hudson right Hudson
so you have a large seat as well right I
think actually we're probably similar um
I have 30,000 constituents I think
you're right around there right um I
can't get to everybody in 4 uh if that's
I can't physically get to everybody um
in a week it's not possible um I knocked
4,500 doors the first time I ran um that
would have been you know roughly 20 30%
of my voters um and that's a lot and
that's more than some people represent
so you you have to when you get these
kind of larger Flo terial districts
larger towns um and you're starting to
see you know ABS ballots tend to be
around 10% of the request right so it's
pretty simple math you know 30,000 times
about 70% eligible registration time 10%
% um you're talking about you know you
end up with like in my case you end up
with about 800 to 900 ABS ballot
requests um once that while the voter
does have an ability to go and pull
their absentee ballot out on Election
Day and that's a whole
another box to unpack um the reality is
is once a voter has sent in their
absentee ballot the likelihood that
they're going to make a correction um or
a change rather it's probably a better
word um is basically slim to none so you
really want to get to as a candidate
who's in a competitive election you
really want to get to that absentee
voter as early as possible as quickly as
possible because they they've raised
their hand and effectively indicated
that they're voting early um I know that
is probably distinction without a
difference but they have effectively
indicated that they are voting early and
you need to get to that voter as soon as
possible so I'll talk about something
that I do and I've mentioned this before
in this committee um is I keep I keep a
huge track of who's taking those abs
ballots um who's requested one from the
general election and I pre-write letter
letters and I hand signed them and I
hand and I put a stamp on them um and I
wait and I wait and I wait until that
town clerk uh drops the ABS ballots in
the mail then I send mine on the same
day um so they get it at the same time
um and I'm very very happy to say that
when they were recounting w six there
were a lot of ballots that had folds in
them that were uh for the opposite party
and then um You' see a bunch of them
with representative Barry check to the
very bottom which is why I won my
election so um turns out if you campaign
um the voters will vote for you if you
representa thank you um thank you for
taking my question I am just curious um
the voters checklist already has an
address in party affiliation how come
the
absentee um voter list doesn't yeah well
it it didn't because of we um it was a
um unintended consequences of how we
wrote the law we used um we use
basically uh we referenced another piece
of RSA that basically said that's the
only information you can get out of the
election net system so we're basically
cracking that open and saying you can
get um you can get the F you can expand
the information you get it's not going
to be like a huge burden um they already
the information's there um it's not
you're not going to be burdening the
town clerk with this they already
pulling the file you're just adding um 1
2 3 four columns to it
have no more questions I have
one one of the problems we have here you
have address where registered but in a
lot of cases abente ballots corre are
going where they're not registered for
example in another couple of weeks um a
for a resident of litfield is
vacationing or summer home in Florida is
going to call me up and ask me who to
vote for so I mean because he's got an
absentee ballot but it's going to
Florida so should that be on your list
um so I mean personally I would support
that I didn't put it on there because I
know that there is contention among the
committee about that um I tried to make
the bill as I I would love to be a 20 on
consent and I knew that if it went to
address where mailed um that I might
lose some people um on a personal level
totally down to have that on there so if
during Z we all agree that that's cool
then I would definitely vote for it um
but I try to um when I bring in
legislation I I like this I try to be
here's where I think we're going to land
um even if it's not everything that I
want it to
be okay sh no more
questions oh
sorry thank you Mr chair just a quick
question representative on line seven
there um it refers to the type of
election the ballot was cast in M aren't
you trying to get these for campaigning
ahead of time you yeah that might be typ
we need to fix your tense is wrong yeah
cuz I guess you're right yeah the bout
hasn't been cashed yet um so I guess
maybe we can fix that good catch yeah
was request see even I can't do it right
the first
time
okay no more oh represent
just a clarification the uh address
where a voter is
registered in the case that my friend
chairman B referenced uh where someone
is spending a great deal of time in
Florida say or as a snowbird would they
not have their mail where they're
registered be forwarded to that other
Home in Florida and wouldn't that
resolve the issue that
it might and I'm definitely down to have
that debate and conversation um it might
it could just be that they're away on
vacation in Aruba um thank you you know
it's it's it's a com
the there's there's information that is
inherently excluded right we don't get
protected voters right um you know
personally on a very personal level I
think you have a right to know where the
ballot went um I I just think you do and
it's not just a campaign perspective
it's I think as a voter and a candidate
you have a right to know where your
ballots are going um but I know not
everybody in the committee holds that
worldview and I I didn't want to um
sounds like we have another vehicle in
which we can explore that uh
conversation I just don't want it to be
this
one
okay thank
you represent Barry next on the list is
henesy good morning everyone Aaron
Hennessy Deputy sake good to see
everybody again
um this um language in the bill would be
something that our office could do um
easily with um creating new reports
within our Statewide voter registration
system um to the Chairman's um testimony
this um the reports would be generated
by our office templates for them and
then your local Clerk or if requested on
a Statewide level our office would um
generate that report through that
template so that no um inappropriate
information would be given out um so
it's something that can be done um very
similar to what is done now uh to
representative Wards point we would
request some language clarification in
in the bill um um in two different
places one is the um type of election
the ballot was cast in I would recommend
that that would be changed to um
election the ballot was requested for um
additionally um the date mailed not all
um absentee ballots are mailed um
sometimes they're hand delivered for
example in January when I went in to get
my um pay my car tax um and my daughter
was registering to vote my clerk asked
if I would like my absentee ballot which
I had already requested and she hand
delivered it to me um so maybe just
semantics around um our system will not
be able to tell you if it was hand
delivered or mailed so just um sent or
another word versus mailed um that would
make sense to you and and um solve any
um questions about if we need to make a
a change in our system or not I'm happy
to take any
questions no representative warry ju uh
just
to um on the possibility that we might
reach a consensus on where where it was
mailed to if if we were to go for that
piece of data as well would that be
readily available or possible through
this mechanism if you were to put in
this bill that we would be required to
also provide the address to which it was
mailed our system would have that and
that
okay with that thank you and no more
people on the list the blue sheet was
at who looked it up um who signed in
electronically so with that I close the
hearing on
11:26 and turn the gavel back over to
the
chair okay o
sorry all right just so we know 1126 the
best bill ever uh 31 support two oppose
Zer neutral in line oh okay the best
bill ever um we're going to stand in
11:05 Cas somebody should asked another
[Laughter]
question uh I don't have 11 I don't have
1134 I think that was the one I had to
go mine was out of order see is behind
it I think there one of them I had to go
order two connotations of
[Laughter]
[Music]
morning
yeah
bille okay 11:05 going to reopen the
Public House election law committee for
the purpos of public hearing on house
1134 relative to inventory controls of
paper ballots we'll recognize our own
representative bham for the purpose of
introduction of the bill representative
burnhams good to see
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee for allowing me to introduce
this bill um so essentially this is just
to uh have
accountability from the Inception of the
ballot um until uh they are uh finally
reconciled and um put away uh um for
such a time if necessary uh this will
help
um local elections and also
um should there be any question as to
the uh amount of ballots um that are
generated and provided by our printer
all the way to um election day as to how
many are received from the local town
level and um as well as the absentee
ballots that are also in that um same
process so it just kind of
clarifies some of the issues that tend
to happen at the end of the evening of
Elections with the moderator checklist
um and
certificate so hopefully all the numbers
balance out and there aren't any backing
up issues that tend to happen that
evening to get the proper numbers so
hopefully that's all I have all
questions from the committee
representative Hamlet thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question sure um so we I just want to
have a clarification about what this is
asking for we we
already uh keep count of how many blank
ballots you know we that are given to
the polling place and how many blank
ballots are given out to voters and then
how many
uh of those ballots are how many blank
ballots are left over at the end so
there's
already a a very
ballots okay so uh what
um what else is this asking
for this is actually at the beginning
phase of the ballots that's not included
such as the order requested from the
printer yep I don't see anybody else
those absolutely thank you um so so how
does that help uh how how does uh how
does that help you know verify the
number of people that actually
voted it's actually tracking the actual
ballot itself not so much how many just
voted but also how many have been
ordered and printed prior to receiving
in the town it kind of adds that
beginning
State yeah keep keep going if any one
else wants to jump in on sure okay so I
I well I guess I don't want to debate it
I just don't understand why that helps
with the accuracy of the the votes um
think that matter I'm sorry I think that
representative weary has some
information to share on
that so he can go into more detail he is
up next thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
Burnham and representative wey is up
welcome thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Robert worry I have the privilege of
serving in Hillsboro County's 13th
District the great town of Hudson
um just want to give a little preamble
to um why this uh particular bill was
put forward um so in December 2022 the
report of special committee on voter
confidence stated that one of the
reasons for high public confidence in
the Safety and Security of New Hampshire
elections is because quote each voter
has a paper
ballot so a proper inventory of printed
ballots
starting at the printer enables the
reconciliation of ballots throughout the
election life cycle to be able to fully
demonstrate accountability of every
paper ballot not just kind of what's
locally in the town but but also what's
produced at the printing
shop um an ability to fully reconcile
ballots um or an inability to fully
reconcile all the printed ballots
creates an uncertainty and may cast out
on the full security of the paper ballot
so to maintain that confidence in the
election um there are certainly some
areas that don't have uh if you will
full accountability yet at least not in
a recorded fashion and so the idea
behind this bill is simply to do that in
I I would say from more of a personal
experience I'm used to dealing with um
highly regulated drugs which have a
certain labeling um that are required
for them and and you're really required
to have a um amount of labels purchased
um and then amount of labels shipped
amount of label used M labels disposed
you know very similar to what we do with
election ballots but it begins with
what's done at the printer and this is
really to kind of get more granular
about those sorts of bits of information
and so that really there's a full
accountability of of that from beginning
to end
and with that I will take any questions
if you wish questions from the committee
resent of H do you have a
question I said I had a feeling that you
would I could just thank you psychic
thank you thank you for taking my
question um I don't think com comparing
the inventory of ballot is a good
comparison to the comparing the
inventory of
prescriptions um can you it's not it's
not prescription it's a it's a label for
the drugs where that is actually tightly
controlled by the Food and Drug
Administration for their regulations so
it it's it's the it's the tight control
inventory and Reconciliation of of
pharmaceutical labeling and and that is
um and the analogy is perhaps that
there's there's a great problem with
counterfeiting in the pharmaceutical
industry industry and that that is
analogous to um concerns that at least
some parties have expressed with regard
to ballots and whatnot so um and misuse
of ballots and this would simply end
frankly further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative wey and last up with the
pink card is our own Secretary of State
Dave
[Music]
scandin Dave David SC do we go David I
don't
know either one is fine Mr
chair uh thank you for the record I'm
Secretary of State David scanlin and I
wanted to take the opportunity to just
inform the committee how the ballot
production process works um I understand
the concerns that are out there about
inventory and you know making sure that
we account for
everything uh the concern I have is that
we can take a to a level that actually
makes us more efficient and and causes
problems with the election process
because we're we're dealing with really
tight time frames as we get in excuse me
close proximity to the election so
hopefully when I explain the process it
will alleviate some of the fears and
concerns that are out there about how
this process works and I know that we
have some local election officials in
the room so you know I think you already
have a you know have some understanding
of this
but when it comes time for an election
the first thing uh that I do as
secretary of state is try to determine
how many voters I think are going to
turn out at the polls on the day of the
election and based on that I will
determine how many ballots both absentee
and official uh that we need to have
printed for every polling place uh in
the state of New
Hampshire and then based on that uh and
based on the filings you we have we have
staff that that design the ballot
according to the requirements in the
statute it takes a tremendous amount of
time to actually proof those ballots and
make sure that they're completely
accurate and even at that even after we
go to print sometimes somebody will find
you know a spelling error or something
uh and I'll talk about how we deal with
that in a second second but the first
thing I do is I come up with a number of
ballots that need to be printed and that
number is delivered to the
printer um we have a uh a relationship
with a local printer that does that
prints the ballots for us um when they
are doing that we have a presence at the
Press with staff in my office so that
they are are there uh kind of overseeing
that process
the ballots are organized by
numbers and we have these big big sheets
of paper that we order from the pul mill
and the the people at the Press will
organize might be four or six or eight
ballots per sheet of paper for the
different towns and uh they run that you
know they they they do that run uh based
on the numbers that I gave
them they excuse me they produced their
own sheet that tells how many ballots
they actually
printed and then when those uh when the
sheets are printed they go to a cutter
and the cutter then Cuts all trims all
the excess paper off so that we're left
with just the
ballots the the towns on an individual
large sheet of paper May vary
somewhat excuse me in
size um and so for you know for one town
we might order 3,000 ballots for another
town it might be 3500 another town it
might be
3250 but in the end the uh the printer
will take the number of ballots that we
ordered from that stack and give them to
the staff that we have in the press that
are actually boxing the ballots up and
shipping them to the individual polling
places the leftover ballots um the
excess ballots I'll say are kept at the
press and we call those overrun ballots
so that if there is a town that feels
like they're getting nervous because
they feel like they're running low on
ballots they call us up what do we do we
usually have those overrun ballots that
we can put in a box and get to them
right away but each step of the way when
I order the ballots we keep track of
that when the printer prints them we
keep track of that so we know how many
ballots was actually printed versus the
order and we have an idea of the number
of overruns that we have at the
Press because we're dealing with so many
sheets of paper in a general election
it's it's well over a million ballots
that we print
uh we don't sit there we don't have
somebody actually counting each stack
they have these uh tools that they call
stab counters that you know will you
kind of push it into the pile and it'll
pull out the set amount it's not perfect
it's usually within one or two uh either
way
so uh we tell the moderator we tell the
town how many ballots are in the box
that they're
receiving but then there's a law that
requ requires the moderator to actually
physically count those ballots once they
get them so they have the exact number
of ballots that they actually received
State
if a town receives overrun ballots
because they got low we keep track of
that we keep track of how many ballots
we sent to them sometimes we have a
candidate that will pass away and if
there is enough time between that event
and the ction and the party gives us the
name of a replacement we will reprint
the whole set of ballots for that town
we keep track of that um some I
mentioned sometimes we find a mistake
you know candidate's name is spelled
wrong or something we will reprint the
ballots and keep track of that but you
know there is a you know we we keep
track of those numbers so then we get to
the election day um and these are the
numbers that are really important it is
the number of ballots that were actually
cast how many ballots went through the
machine and how many were handc counted
combined uh or if it's a hand countown
how many you know ballots came out of
the box and they were counted and then
comparing that number with the number of
Voters that checked in on the day of the
election and hopefully they match um
sometimes there's more ballots than
voters checked in and that's usually
because the ballot cler got to
socializing a little bit too much and
somebody forgot to cross a name off the
checklist so you know if there's a a two
or three vote variation there we don't
get too excited about that um if it's
much larger then uh we have to figure
out
why when we do our training with local
election officials we we uh give them
different ways that they can reconcile
the numbers that they have at the end of
the night and you know it might be
finding a couple of the major candidates
on the ballot getting their totals
adding in the undervotes and the and the
overvotes in a particular race you know
closely it it is not unusual because
this is not a perfect system that you
know there is minor variations in those
numbers and uh that's why you see the
election officials get really excited if
everything matches exactly um and
sometimes they just don't you know some
sometimes it's it's late at night and
sometimes they're tired and the numbers
are off and they just can't figure it
out um they send us the report as it is
and then we try and sit down with them
after the election you know to help them
reconcile uh as best we can those
numbers when the election is over all of
the cast ballots are stored in sealed by
boxes and all of the uncast ballots that
were sent to the polling place are
stored in sealed boxes there is no
requirement at a recount that you know
the the uncast ballots have to be
counted up uh the law just says that the
cast ballots are counted uh at a recount
and so that is what we do but we have
all of the physical evidence if we had
to you know reconcile a you know the
number of ballots that were uh printed
and used at an election for an election
with in reason uh are there and those
summary numbers that I mentioned to you
we do keep track of and they're
available you know upon request for um
anyone that's
interested and then the last thing that
I would like to offer the committee is
uh
you know if one or two or you know
individually want to come to the Press
while we're printing ballots we'll be
happy to escort you through that process
so you can see exactly how it works the
security measures uh that are in place
and the fact that the whole process is
overseen directly by uh my myself or my
staff uh at the
printer be happy to answer any questions
all right question of the committee
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for that explanation it was
very helpful can you talk about how
spoiled ballots are accounted
for a so if a voter uh makes a mistake
on their ballot they go to the moderator
uh and ask for a new one the moderator
will write spoiled on uh the back of the
ballot and initial it and then keep
those uh ballots so that they are they
are uh
kept and maintain along with the all the
other ballot materials from that
election uh sealed in a box and when we
conduct a recount boxes open up the
spoiled ballots are there so that you
know people can see that there were
ballots of that
nature follow up ribs and Bone you want
to yield yep if I understand your
testimony correctly it sounds like you
are s satisfied with the inventory
controls for accountability of paper
ballots am I understanding your
testimony correctly I'm satisfied yes my
my job is to help you understand that so
you're satisfied and that's the that's
the goal here and we need to do that to
instill confidence in our elections it's
not what I believe it's what everybody
else believes it's involved in this
process thank you Vice chairman
M thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question more of a statement
would you believe some decades
ago we were running I was selectman and
we were running out of ballots and I
called the Secretary of State's office
and they said oh we have some and I
still couldn't now till this day why
would you have more balance that we
didn't have and you answered the
question so and that's it's a good point
that our state law has a process for
dealing with time that might run out of
ballots and in the first instance uh
when when a town runs out of official
ballots they're supposed to keep
one uh and then start using leftover
absentee ballots the clerk should
initial those to make them official
ballots and then they can be passed out
to the voters if the town runs out of
the absentee ballots Then That official
ballot that was held can be copied uh
but the clerk has to initial every
single copy that is used making that an
official ballot and then those have to
be accounted for in the inventory at the
end of the night uh you when the
moderator is filling out the
paperwork fun times further questions
representative P Brian thank you uh I
appreciate the invitation to see the
ballots printed and I'll take you up on
that we have that happening soon with
the local elections so um before you go
any further on that the the towns are
responsible for the ballots at their
local election so the next
opportunity uh for the state will be
leading up to the state primary thank
you thank you representative wood oh I
had a followup
but all right you can have your followup
okay thank you so I don't want to cast
dispersions on any specific printing
company so I'll just say in general if
there was a printing
company that was in involved in printing
ballots and they were very if they were
very sloppy and they took their extra
printed ballots and they just put them
unattended
outside you're confident that even if a
company was sloppy like that that your
process would be
um would would have the highest of uh
integrity and there wouldn't
be the option for someone to take those
ballots and put them into the system and
then try to cast them as if they were
voters that had cast them um so we would
not deal with a sloppy printer company
and and the printing of ballots is one
area where we don't have to go out to
bid you know to find a printer we can go
with a printer that we know we'll do a
good job you know that we trust uh we
keep the local the printer local so that
if we have to you know react quickly to
some issue uh you know we can do that um
so the printer that we have now um and
the printer that we had uh probably a
dozen years ago that was different we
had the highest confidence in uh you the
way they ran their business you know was
all first class um and they worked with
us very very
well representative wood thank you Mr
chair thank you m Mr secretary uh thank
you for the explanation on uh the early
explanation now I know you explanation
was a thorough but looking at this um
inventory control on the front end when
the order do you feel that this is
already being
accomplished from what you understand of
the of the spill yes yes we keep track
of the numbers that are being requested
at the front end um and and as I said
you know we can Pro produce those okay
so if the follow up please uh so if
there is um
overruns um that are outside of what you
they normally expect you would know that
what you normally expect because usually
when you do printing there's normal
overruns and there's accidental overruns
those those there's very sta varying
stages but you feel that's under control
yes and so the overruns are put on these
carts and they are kept you know in our
staff Presence at the printer so you
know we know where they are if if
there's a request for overruns from a
town
it's my staff that are the ones that go
and retrieve it box it seal it and make
sure the towns get
it thank you further
questions representative P
Brian again thank you for that detailed
explanation I really appreciate it I
appreciate your conscientiousness and
the conscientiousness of the printer
that you work with and that you choose
for those uh
attributes should this be codified in
law so that seven eight 10 Secretary of
States in the future we'll be using the
exact same process and the and the and
people will know that that's what's
happening that's a question I had not
um I my preference would be to leave it
like it is you know and then if if
there's an issue in the future then you
know then tighten the screws a little
bit but during the time that we were
printing the ballots the the printer
actually keeps the doors to the building
locked even during business hours you
know for somebody to enter they have to
ring the doorbell to get in and then
there's a log that's kept of every
single person that enters uh the
building with their contact
information further questions seeing
none thank you Mr secretary I don't have
any of the pink cards in my possession
um Can somebody toss me that blue
sheet and look at that just in time on
line
34 uh on line 35 in support 10 opposed
zero neutral no one signed up on the
blue sheet with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 11:34
and immediately open up the right on
time uh open up the public hearing on
house below 11:36 relative to requiring
a reconcil a Reconciliation of votes
cast and undervotes with the total
number of ballots as um and I saw
represent Andrews are you here to
introduce the bill representive
yes good morning honorable house
election committee I am here this
morning regarding this bill and
is there was an issue in my district and
we would never have known about it if
there hadn't been a
recount now in the end these papers I'm
passing passing around had the rec has
the recount in my district and I believe
there is a problem and maybe other
districts where they hand count the
ballots 14 errors in 5 PBS is not
acceptable I've been a bookkeeper all my
life and uh one in one always had to
make two
and I realize people are tired at the
end of the day when they count the
ballots and all that but we have to do
recount somebody might have been W lost
the election and just walked away and I
would probably one of those people that
would have just walked away and never
asked for a
recount I don't know all the answers to
this and I'm looking to each member of
you on the committee to help and I'm not
going to keep you because like I said I
don't have all the answers I just wish
we could find a way in the law to make
people
accountable when they count the ballots
thank
you all right uh will you be taking
questions represent
Andrews yep okay she had to think about
it so everybody very nice are the
questions from the
committee okay seeing none thank you
representative
Andrews one other pink card is deputy
Hennessy good morning everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of
state um a little bit of background uh
when we do our training for our election
officials um and I I know some of you in
here have gone to that training uh we do
a lot of talking um either in person or
um in our online trainings about
reconciliation process as a CPA um
non-practicing I love um when numbers
work out and uh doing reconciliation was
something I did in my former life um so
I usually take over the training on the
reconciliation process um one different
thing we did this year in the
presidential primary
um was that for each of the um ballots
um for the return of votes not the
actual ballots um The Return of votes
were set up like a
Reconciliation and we could do this
because um there was just one One race
um even though there was many candidates
on it there was one race so we set it up
to um show um to help the moderators
reconcile the number of ballots uh the
number of votes cast for a candidate
including the rins um the number of
undervotes and the number of
overvotes um and yes there are
undervotes um even with um just one um
race being run so
um the
um some of the um reconciliations were
done really well um some of them had
difficulty one of the issues that we we
came across with the reporting of
undervotes on the election return this
year was that um there was a big um
campaign for a write in campaign and the
way a um our acote system uh B
electronic ballot counting devices are
set up is that if a ballot is completely
blank um so in a um in a presidential
primary election if somebody didn't fill
in the oval but they wrote a name in The
Ballot accounting device would see that
as a completely Bank blank ballot those
are um diverted into different bin um or
if the diverter is not working at some
places they they manually go through
every single ballot to see if there's
any writings um but the um if it is
diverted um the ballot counting device
will report that as an undervote um and
the counting the hand counting teams
will see those ballots and they will see
them as a write in for a candidate as
they're instructed to do because if
somebody writes the a name in but
doesn't fill in the oval the voter
intent is for that person who they WR
the a in for but one interesting thing
on the reconciliation or the return of
votes was that some of our towns didn't
realize that they have to reduce the
number of O undervotes because they've
increased the number of of wrin um so
that was a a
tricky a tricky thing that some of our
moderators didn't quite grasp with this
um with this election in particular and
I think just the number of wrin votes um
Statewide really put a highlight on that
so we will be planning on doing more
training on the um on the undervote side
of things where even though you're tape
says one thing for undervotes you have
to reconcile it to the number of writin
that you've recorded where the bubble
was not filled in so that being said um
I want I just wanted to give you this
story to show you that the
reconciliation process is not an easy
process um especially for somebody um
who doesn't deal with numbers all the
time and and say um it's midnight or if
you were with me in Windom um past
midnight
um it's it's not an easy process um so
there there are um some mistakes that
are made but um in looking at the
language of this bill this would require
that um every reconciliation would be
done um on the return of votes but it
does not require um the reconciliation
to include overvotes um and that would
be um I see that just as a an error
because you always have to include
overvotes um in your reconciliation
otherwise um you don't get the total
number of um votes cast we call it some
of all votes so um I would if you're
going to pass this bill I would
recommend you include overvotes but one
thing that we would have would be
difficult for our office to do would be
to include a Reconciliation on the
return of votes for every single office
or question on the ballot so in the
general election um we would have to
include a Reconciliation on the return
of votes for every single race that
there is including any constitutional
question or if your town is going to
vote on changing your polling hours um
it's going to get an extremely
lengthy number of pages for each return
of votes um
and um in our training we always train
our ction officials to do
reconciliations we have not trained them
to do um a Reconciliation for every
single question or um or race uh we we
do recommend that they do at least three
um just to make sure that everything has
reconciled and for your information the
reconciliation would be the sum of all
votes to the number of ballots cast to
the number of Voters checking in so it's
we call it the three legs of our stool
so the number of votings Voters checking
in should equal the number of physical
ballots that were cast should equal the
sum of all votes that were cast with
that I'm happy to take questions other
questions from the commit represent
gab thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so I guess this
particular sheet doesn't have the number
of undervotes on here however I do see
some of the Merit in it because I know
when I look to win even in the recount
that was done for example there was two
recounts done one for district uh 17 and
one for District 35 District 35 happened
at like 10: in the morning and I don't
know District 17 was at like 12:30 but
nonetheless if you look at the at the
voters checked in it was
2033 and then if you end up looking at
the district 35 recount it equates to
226 ballots and then the 17 recount
equates to 232 ballots so it seems like
in between those two recounts there were
definitely some ballots missing and I
could see the same thing potentially
knowing how thoroughly it's done at the
recount and there were still B ballots
missing that there could be some done
some missing at the election but I guess
what would we do if they did realize
that there was some missing what what
Authority would the town have if they
said hey our numbers aren't working out
the right way it seems like some of
these votes weren't counted what could
they do about
it um so I think there was a lot of
questions in there but um sorry I I
apologize I don't know what you're
looking at in front of you um
but I don't sorry I don't know what that
is um I don't I don't have it it's the
original numbers of the votes in this
district and then the recounts that
happened after but the the overvotes are
missing from here so that's why I just
equated another District where I did see
that some the numbers are off in that
one as well so that's why I was so yeah
to do a proper reconciliation you would
need the overvotes um otherwise the
numbers are not going to reconcile
unless there were no overvotes um to
what uh secretary scanland testified to
in in the last um in the last bill um
this is a human process um and I and I
if anyone has not been to a recount I
recommend going there um there are two
people that physically count each of the
ballots um and they take turns um
sometimes you will witness um the two
people not having the same number and so
they count and they count and they count
so there is there's sometimes where the
ballots will stick together and they
just cannot even though how many times
one person counts it they're not going
to get the same number but they stay
until they figure oh yes you got 25 I
got 25 so that just goes to highlight
there may be an instance where one
person counts it two ballots were stuck
together another person counts it two
ballots were stuck together so I can't
explain why and I haven't looked at it
what um why those count of those ballots
would be different but they're there
could be instances where two people
count the same pile and they come up
with the same number but it is an
incorrect number because it is a human
process yes that's fine so I guess what
I'm asking is though if they did this
process where they realized at the night
of the election
that counting the overvotes undervotes
and like let's say it was a vote vote
four they divided and they said nope
like we were supposed to have 2,000
ballots this is only accounting for
19900 90 ballots if we did this process
what what value is it going to add
because what can they do with that
information how can they figure out
where those 10 votes are missing from
what Authority do they have to check
that I guess is what I'm really trying
to get at so at the the night of the
election we train the moderators not to
announce the results until they've done
a
Reconciliation um and I've been at a
polling location where they realize that
they did not include the um ballots from
the side pocket the some some places
they have very few side pocket ballots
they did removed those side pocket
ballots they just didn't include them in
their final count and once they did it
was within one or two votes and they
were happy that they had done that
reconciliation because otherwise those
side pet ballots wouldn't have been
counted so they they have authority to
continue to count until they've
announced their numbers and taped
everything up and sealed it and once the
ballots are sealed in the boxes they
don't have an authority to open them
back up representative Howard thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh so because the uh
reconciliation does happen at the end of
the night and uh under uh RSA 659 73 uh
section 4 uh part L there is the
statement of for each contest or ballot
question the number of overvotes and
undervotes uh so and of course that's
under uh section four which states the
moderator shall fill out a moderator uh
certificate prepared by the secretary of
state which shall be recorded and signed
by the moderator within 48 Hours uh of
closing the polls or other time ordered
by the Secretary of State and submitted
to the clerk uh the worksheet shall
include uh set information uh because
this already takes place and is already
covered by part L uh is there a reason
Bill thank you for the question um I and
I I can't speak to the intent of the
sponsor but I think the sponsor was
actually looking for a Reconciliation
and and I don't maybe if you choose to
do this you would specify what that
reconciliation would include I know we
train people that the reconciliation is
to sum of all votes the number of Voters
checking in and the ballots
cast thank you further questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
deputy secretary of state uh next up is
Derry and representative anenberg if you
good morning uh thank you for allowing
me to speak in front of the committee uh
my name is Tina Guilford I'm the dairy
town clerk um I used to be the dery town
moderator I'm very familiar with
reconciliation overvotes undervotes
total
voters we're a vote 10 town for State
Rep you want to talk about a race that's
difficult ult to
reconcile I will tell you however um
that something that gets forgotten and
there's lots of people that like to look
at numbers and they play they do the
math and they do all these
things when you report your total voters
you report your total
voters on that
day not every voter in a September
primary or a November race or a November
election is actually eligible to vote in
every single
race so that reconciliation you need to
be very careful when looking at your
total voters versus total
votes um because there are federal
office only voters so if you're looking
at the total voters that voted in an
election and you want the numbers to all
total that may not happen on the further
down ballot races that are not federal
and I don't know what exactly you were
looking at but I just want to make sure
that everybody is aware that a
Reconciliation like this would need to
actually break that all out um and
you're talking about pages and pages of
paperwork we actually use a spreadsheet
in Dair to keep track of this um I I
know some other towns do as well to make
sure that we have counted all votes at
the end of the night but um I I don't
know what all the other towns do but I
do want to caution people from just um
looking at something and thinking oh
well it should all total CU sometimes
that number may change based on the
eligible voters that's all and I will
take any questions okay any questions
about the dreaded Foo ballot federal
office
only all right seeing none thank you um
there's no one else signed up to speak
the blue sheet was empty online there
was 31 people signed in in support to
opposed uh with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on house B 11:36 the
committee will stand in res in recess uh
until 1 p.m. for the introduction of
[Music]
lunch
because that's the only votes they get
they're usually overseas voters yeah and
federal
okay it's 1:00 we're going to reopen the
public hearings for the house election
law committee going to open the public
hearing for house Bel 1157 relative to
over voted and under voted ballots going
to rep recognize representative C
representative C is on loan to us his
committee is currently in caucus during
executive session so he won't be able to
take any questions from us today
unfortunately so he's going to do a a
driveby introduction representative C
it's good to see it's good to see
you thank you Mr chairman and members of
election law committee um I'm
introducing uh House Bill uh I'm Al
representative Alvin C from Lowden and I
represent uh eight towns in a floral
District in marac County um I'm
introducing House Bill
1157 uh relative to over voted and under
voted ballots and this bill was a
intended to provide a way for the new
digital electronic ballot counting
devices to prove that they can process
ballots without having large numbers of
reported overvotes as we have seen with
the old ACU vote
machines i'
originally I was originally encouraged
to make the uh legislation consistent
with all devices authorized to use for
use in New Hampshire and that all voters
would have equal experience but on
reflection there there will never be
equal experiences
for uh for all voters since some voters
will be in machine count towns others in
hand count towns uh other cases would be
iners versus absentee voting and we can
make a long list of
of there two two classes of uh voters so
um with that i' like to introduce
Amendment 2024
0589 h to address the new digital ball
counting devices and to take advantage
of features that these devices have to
enhance the voting
experience okay is that all you got for
us um I'd like to uh continue to discuss
the amendment if I may you I will I will
allow the hearing to continue on the
amendment as a courtesy without
objection thank you uh the amendment
calls for the uh new devices to be
programmed to um when when you put a
ballot in before you before it actually
counts and adds in the total of B votes
on it hold it if it detects any
overvotes undervotes or blank
ballots and gives the in-person voter a
chance to um take the ballot back to
correct it or to uh pass it uh have the
machine accepted as
is the um and this this is a
um uh something that the uh help America
voter Act is is uh wants us to
do as written the U this amendment will
leave the old ACU votes alone without
any changes these devices will still be
programmed to return to the voter any
ballot which the device detects as an
overvote the new digital ballot counting
devices use different techn know you to
read the ballots and determine how the
voter cast his or her
votes this should be much more immune to
incorrectly detecting overvotes as
compared to the old ACU vote devices the
new devices will still need to be
programmed to report the number of
overvotes and undervotes for each office
or question on the ballot so that they
can um be on the uh election night
returns uh per RSA
the candidates in cities and towns using
new devices should closely monitor
election night reports as to the number
of overvotes and computer with um
compare with results of
needed and this should be done even if
this uh Bill and amendment is not pass
the new machine should be watched
closely when the absence ballots are
being processed if they're being run
through the machine the election
official can just select the accept the
ballot as
is uh it's not stated in the bill but
the election official May uh put in the
um bot absentee ballots in the auxiliary
compartment for later hand counting if
they detect things that may make the
ballot unreadable such as a torn Ballot
or um tape on it or any other issues
them and um the only um other thing that
ought to be U looked at just in in case
you want to consider it um if the
ballots are returned for undervotes that
may slow down the election process for
the
whole um election simply because a lot
of of people don't bother voting for all
offices on the ballot so that could be
an issue um and you you could amend this
to just only deal with overvotes if you
uh
wanted um so with that I'd like to
encourage you to vote off to pass with
the bill and the amendment and uh
unfortunately I would like to take
questions but I need to run back to my
committee for exec session all right
thank you representative c um I don't
have any other pink cards on this bill
um if you could pass the blue sheet over
um online
1157 had 18 people in support nine
opposed um and I'm going is the sheet
blank same me the
time no no somebody signed
in one one one person signed up not
speaking that was opposed uh with that
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 11:57 committee will stand in
recess until
1:25 um I would highly recommend that
both parties take this respective time
to caucus before our executive session
so that we can get out of here even
okay and we're back um going to open up
the house election law committee public
hearing um going to start with House
Bill
1149 relative to domicile residency
voter registration investigation of
voter verification letters relative to
the terms resident inhabitant residence
and residen
um I believe
representative Horan is here to
law thank you I served on Election law
my first term with uh former resident
Bob Perry who sitting in the audience um
I've gotten much older than them Bob is
still the same so
uh um anyway I'm represent Timothy
Horgan from straford County District 10
the town of Durham um which I guess is a
may have something to do with why I
introduced this bill and um and my I've
written testimony which I submitted
submitted to the website um and I know
one other individual did somebody from
granted State taxpayers and he I just
want to caution you I don't know whether
he's coming in or not or most of you
probably seen the testimony he's going
about the address on the driver's
license being proof of residency and
that's not necessarily always the case
you know you are when you move either
from one state to another or within a
state you're supposed to change your
driver's license Within I think it's 60
days or some period of time but the
penalty for not doing so is merely a
minor motor vehicle uh violation it's
not a MISD demeanor so you shouldn't
lose your right to vote just because you
forgot neglected or forgot to change
your address on your driver's license
but anyway just thought I'd do a
preemptive thing without like amplifying
his testimony too much and this bill and
I'm sure most of you been in this
committee for a while you certainly were
all here last year uh it's virtually
identical to hb40 2023 which came before
this committee last year also the same
as HP 538 which came to the committee 3
years ago HP40 ended up being tabled and
died on the table HP 538 was introduced
in the covid-19 emergency as one of
several dozen bills all of which were
ited in community which ended up never
getting a floor vote which wasn't really
supposed to happen but those were
strange times and exceptional
circumstances um and now it's 2024 and
I'm back um HB 538 is now HB
1149 It's a combination of two bills
which I sponsored with many co-sponsors
in 2019 passed the House and Senate
before being vetoed by the
governor and um HB 106 covered the sing
arounds the Senate bill which was also
vetoed in 2019 um anyway so this bill
looks long looks complicated if passing
the law it would simply undo three
earlier bills which in my opinion and
other people opinions unfairly restrict
voting rights generally make the voting
process less user friendly or to put it
in another way uh more user
hostile and those three bills which all
passed between 20 was 20 hp 1264 passed
in 2018 sp3 in 2020
2017 and S SP 318 in 2012 sp3 is one
that made the more changes is like you
know the most
controversial um so I live in Durham
which is a college town um students
living here they're not the only voters
who are adversely affected by the
changes of voting right laws which uh HB
1149 aims to undo but my constituent in
dur was a college town they they do
perceive uh these changes in Attack the
students uh right to vote and then every
any um every any citizen over the age of
18 has the right to be vote in the
community where he or she lives and we
can play games with semantics but like
college students and other people who
have just been in town a short time are
still res still residents and still Idol
to claimed the places are domicile and
um so you have the right to live in the
community where you live and make that
your domicile and it doesn't matter why
you moved here it doesn't really we
don't have a durational voting
requirements it doesn't matter how long
ago and if we had a durational voting
requirement that's usually for about a
month or so you know so much much
shorter period of time than people such
as college students it also affects uh
military
personnel maybe people who are people
who think they're living someplace
temporarily to do a job and then stay on
and a number of other peoples but it's
primarily the controversy is mostly
about students who do have the right to
vote in fact should be encouraged to
vote because a good lifetime um lifetime
um habits so the I'm Point your
attention the second
article article 11 part 1 of our state
constitution all elections are to be
free in every inhabitant of the state at
18 years age mother shall have an equal
right to vote in any election every
person shall be considered an inhabitant
for voting in the town Ward or
unincorporated place where he could
could also at some point we should
probably have a cicr to change that to
he or she or they but
anyway he has his domicile and the
domicile um has a somewhat complicated
concept but a lot of the commentary
about Doan residency is just plain false
like for example what may be about to
hear from the grand estate taxpayers
organization so anyway basically if you
live here in New Hampshire you can vote
here period and that's what the law says
that's what it should be and this rather
lengthy bill is just simply putting the
voter fors back to where they are
because I think they more accurately
reflected that constitutional reality so
that's a that's my bill I know most of
you went through the whole hearing
almost exactly a year ago but um if you
have any questions I'd be happy to try
to answer them
committee representative weary yep
thanks uh thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Horgan for taking my
question
um I'm reminded of the great Cole Porter
musical anything goes um it seems like
you're removing any restrictions from
any so anyone comes in here at any time
can
vote if they're in the for more than a
an evening is
that um what you're that's what you're
implying here that's not my intent I
know many people believe that that's
what even the current law says and what
it said before that's simply uh that's
simply not true everybody who wants to
vote needs uh proof of identity which
can include a driver's license proof of
residency and also proof of citizenship
so um
if you have those three things here um
it doesn't really matter why you lived
why you move to the place where you are
and um technically I guess if you move
here just for a day and then vote and go
away that I believe could be a violation
of election law but there's a not any
evidence of large numbers of people uh
large numbers of people doing that even
though there's sort of a belief but the
evidence you know nobody for example
there's a legendary voter buses from
Massachusetts no one has actually seen
those buses no one has ever infiltrated
those buses no one has man to get a
picture of them so you wonder like uh I
maybe I shouldn't have brought that up
that's something I know many people
believe is true but there's absolutely
no evidence of it in fact people in
Massachusetts or any other state they
want to vote in their own States
election they're not really all that
concerned with with ours um so um I
would just say no anything doesn't go
and we're just putting the law the way
it was back to 2012 and that law had
been in place for a long time and uh you
know and anything didn't go back then
anything doesn't go now anything isn't
going to go um if we pass my bill so
that's my answer
thanks further questions from the
committee representative P Brian thank
you thank you for taking my
question I'm looking at page
13 for uh registering more than 30 days
in advance of an election and it's all
struck out so this bill would also
remove the requirement that someone
would have
a driver's license to show their
identity uh a government ID with a photo
on it to show their identity um a
government issued check a benefit
statement or tax document to show their
identity what would be acceptable to
show their identity maybe just a note
from someone or um well you um You
probably actually does anybody have an
extra copy of the bill I think I brought
a bunch of paper but not that one see
exactly what you're talking about I
think
them I mean certainly before that you
still had to show ID when when
registering we did put in a thing we
have to show it at the polling place
which this does
um which this does uh make this would
would change so yes see line 13 yes
Crossing out uh is crossing a lot of
language that was added about uh there's
a special procedure currently for if
you're 30 days advance of the election
but
I I believe and you may want have a work
session or call on the Secretary of
State to get the straight answer um of
it but this bill has been introduced
several times um it would go back to the
old form which still required ID and
proof do you live there and all that
stuff so that's I I I think your I think
your fears fears are unfounded you're
certainly um certainly welcome to call
have a work session and ask the
Secretary of State exactly what the
current law said says what the current
law didn't but that's um that's my
answer thanks so it might just
understand so this bill when you say
show a for of ID you're including in
that definition an
affidavit just to clarify well there is
a procedure for an affidavit for
somebody who's missing some of the
documentation I think we now recently we
put in a provisional ballot the number
of those affidavit is pretty pretty
small but uh they do include that as a
workaround you still you're feeling that
under penalty of perjury so you know if
you uh you're taking a big risk if you
file a false Avid Aid so that's
especially since people are uh keeping
an eye on it that is something that's a
lot of concern about in the public so so
followup if I may unless somebody wants
to jump in so this would repeal s SP 418
or
no SP 318 sp3 and hb1 1264 but then it
reenacts the previous law which covered
um pretty much pretty much the same
ground as what those three bills have
put in place so yes so we would be going
back to a system where you can show up
to the voting to the polling location
with
nothing and be just be handed a ballot
or am I just am I off base on this I'm
try trying to figure out what this bill
does well a little little off base it is
theoretically to file um those three
requirements if you don't have the
paperwork and you're willing to testify
so under penalty perjury you you could
fill out affidavits if I recall
correctly and I don't know about the
Comm we have a provisional valid
procedure in place which I think exactly
I think maybe one person used it in the
Manchester mayor election so that's it's
not not a large number of people even
before that who were like going that
route so I don't think it's affected any
elections so got it okay representative
Howard thank you uh and thank you for
taking my question uh so under Section 8
on page 20 uh it says that the Secretary
of State may become a member of a
program or organization who is composed
of State local uh DC or voting
territories uh election officials from
the United States whose purpose is to
share and exchange information to
improve accuracy and efficiency of voter
registration system does this mean that
you would enable the uh SOS to enroll Us
in something like
Eric
I I believe it would you may want to
yeah that's a I'm not 100% sure they
answer that question it certain be
appropriate for them under certain
circumstances toh to do so and they have
in the past it does mention one
particular Interstate voter rtion cross
check program which was uh that was like
several years ago but it that
organization made had a lot of problems
it
was it was a system for matching the
names to names other states was like
throwing out huge numbers of false
positives and so we are trying to
trying to make it unable for them to
participate in that one but yeah they
can you know I don't think that I think
it's think either before right now and
after this bill passed I think I believe
they'll still be able to participate in
such programs and once again you may
want to you know may want to take
another look at it even though I
sponsored this bill several times and
it's been been looked at by OS multiple
times and the Secretary of State's
office multiple times but yes okay thank
you further questions from the committee
representative
Lane thank you Mr chair and thank
representative hgan to your knowledge
was anyone ever convicted or accused of
voter fraud convicted of voter fraud
under this law when it existed prior to
the numerous
changes basically basically no there's a
few cases of voter fraud and they're not
necessarily the type of individual that
certain people worry about committing
voter fraud who had usually it's
somebody who a lot of times ironically
they seemen hard a lot of times you see
ironically not necessar neily be be
Democrats and not necessarily young I
mean occasionally somebody will vote in
uh Massachusetts for example another
state of New Hampshire but it's a
handful of people and the
Secretary State and the Attorney General
have a robust system in place for trying
to catch people to do that and some
people actually have been prosecuted but
um I don't know it's not hordes of
people anyway
thanks further questions on the
committee all right I will end with this
one because it's my favorite question to
ask when we get to voter ID
if somebody signs an affidavit and you
haven't seen their driver's license so
you don't know where they live you don't
know who they are who they say they are
how do you track them down to prosecute
them people have been people have been
tracked down and prosecuted the driver's
license by the way is not a requirement
to vote you're nobody's allowed to carry
a driver's license although then you
lose your and that's primarily designed
to show that you're qualified to operate
a motor vehicles it's not and it's not
really um a proof of address and I think
hardly maybe a few people believe it's a
proof of citizenship but it's not that
either so that's uh you know the the
actual who signs out the affidavit and
what happens to is a matter of public
record and it's a very manageable number
of people so they uh you know so that's
that's my answer there we're kind of
like a this is um I think these laws
were a passw where the usually old
cliche we have here they were Solutions
in search of a problem but
okay uh with that seeing no other
questions thank you representative Horan
I don't have anyone else signed up to
speak on this bill um so can you I
didn't look online yet that's my
apologies can you guys pass me the blue
sheet and I
was reading chapter l so I don't have my
phone on the right screen
1140 nobody 11 okay uh there's no one
one one again and oh yep uh one person
signed up who didn't speak and they were
and that was the Secretary of State's
office um so uh and let me get the
online here why it would help if I could
count all right here we go all right
11:49 we had 20 signed up in support 60
in opposition Zer neutral and with that
I will close the public hearing on House
Bill
1149 and the committee will stand in
okay it's 150 means we're back going to
open up the public hearing on House Bill
1348 relative to polling places at which
total ballot counts exceed the total
number of registered voters uh
representative wer will you be
introducing this bill I will be all
right representative Wier chair we have
a uh celebrity chair of
Finance the committee that no one in
this room will ever be good enough to be
on
me it's the best Committee in the house
God bless God bless anybody who wants
wants to sit on
finance get to hear everything but then
again they probably say that about
election law so or they don't
representative
wer can can you hit your microphone for
me see we in election law we use the
microphon that's a good idea see it's I
I went both directions so now
everybody's happy right now we're all
happy I went both directions all
right
okay
[Music]
congratulations with all the bills you
time very
good so 10 years ago the secretary of
state would declare a good turnout for
presidential election if the
participation was
50% in 2016 the legislature ordered the
Secretary of State to write letters to
all the same day registrants in that
election we were get letting them get
away with affidavits that year he was
somewhat selective in whom he mailed to
but over 8,000 letters were sent out 5
5,300 came back as
undeliverable no such person at that
address the results of the 2016 election
was somewhat surprising the Republicans
had a 220 to 170 majority in the house
the Senate was 14 to10
Republicans however both Congress people
and the Senate went
Democrat one might conclude that the
5,300 fake votes were all for Democrats
and the illegal voters only did the top
of the ballot so they could hurry to the
next polling place and fill out more
affidavits that was my conclusion when I
would go in to warm up at my polling
place and the the seven or eight seats
at the table for affidavits always
filled somebody would finish the
paperwork they get up another person
would sit down and fill out paperwork in
my little place of couple of thou of
couple thousand voters there must have
been
affidavits I found some election results
some election audits that an auditor did
for the 2022 election normally we see a
lower turnout in a midterm election she
states that New Hampshire had a close to
90% turnout for the 2022 election and
due to same day registrations she finds
22 polling places where the numbers
exceeded
100% I'm convinced that we are still
seeing a massive cheating in our
elections and the results would seem to
indicate that it is a democratic funded
Affair a few years ago a package from
China broke open while it was being
unloaded at O'Hare Airport the picture
showed many fake driver's license we
need far more efforts to stop this
illegal voting in our state this bill is
only one small step I'm hopeful that
this committee will see the need to pass
it in the 2020 election some secretaries
of State Certified election where the
ballots outnumbered the population we
need to give our secretary this tool and
I'll on the back side of my piece I show
you how much information we know about
the voting age population and this is
available by town and City so that they
should be able to know how many people
there are in that town that are over
18 and that should be the N the maximum
number of
votes and I recall uh counties in
Michigan where the ballots vastly
outnumbered the total population and yet
it was certified so this is the sort of
thing if our secretary of state has a
law that says I can't certify this
polling place
because the the ballots
outnumber the residents or outnumber the
voting residents so that's that's my
attempt to try to stifle some of this
cheating that goes on and this uh 2022
election she did find several places
where they brought in bunches of people
to go sign up to vote that day more than
they should have been by the numbers of
registered voters even including the
ones registering that day happy to
answer any questions thank you okay
questions from the
committee seeing none representative
bom's not going to let you get away that
easy question
um so what about I'm my issue on this
is there are people that legally
voted so what do we do to fix that their
vote shouldn't be negated uh should we
have a another election I mean just say
that um that those votes don't count so
how do you think we should fix it what
else can you do if if somebody comes in
and dumps a bunch of phony ballots
they've been the ones that destroyed the
election in that polling place not the
not the legitimate voters what else can
we do but say we can't count this it's
been flawed yeah and also you mentioned
follow up thank you uh I remember some
years ago in Kings County Seattle
Washington where the governor's race and
they kept recounting the ballots over
and over again then even after the
ballots were counted they and they took
it to court and the judge ruled it out
because even know it proved that in
King's County they had 10% more votes
than residents in King County so I mean
but what you know and it was
certified I I assume this is a would you
believe yeah but thing all right sorry
problem is what I think we still need to
do something like it's terrible to
negate a legitimate vote right but the
the it was negated by the Crooked people
that that
voters representative wood thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh I noed a couple of things here in
item six 90% turnout what's a typical
turnout do do you how we compare that to
typical turnout in
2022 do you have information on that I'm
not even talking about the 100% the 2022
had had an average of 90% so all of it
was at average a 90% so average all of
it average 90% but 22 polling places out
of the hundreds had more than 100% yeah
so I'm one of those people that like oh
can I have a follow sorry I was having a
must I fell asleep I was having no I was
having a um a voter age participation
VAP flashback okay um my mind was
wandering go ahead thank thank you Mr
chair uh the 90% I find high I I'm one
of the people that like to play with
numbers that we we hear about in this
this group I find a 90% high so how what
answer did you get for 100% I mean that
I mean I'm sure you got this information
you you you talked to SEC have you
talked to the Secretary of State what's
his answer to this I I've talked with
with his people that investigate this
sort of thing and they claim it's very
low now since 2016 because they didn't
allow for the affidavits but when I know
there's phony I out there then the the
amount of numbers that this auditor
showed um that were coming out typically
there was 20 to 25 to 30% same day
registrant which I think we would all
find somewhat
surprising but especially a midterm
election yeah I I will regret this but
representative Mirad is
recognized it's a simple point point of
clarification thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking the question are are you
saying that the average turnout in the
state of New Hampshire in the 2022
election was 90% that's what this
auditor said over the whole state over
the whole state thank you which is you
know I remember when uh Sumit election
oh we had a big turnout
53% and that I remember that for years
and years that's what they would say oh
big turnout 50 50 some per. uh we
actually representative Brennan she had
her hand up unless she wishes to
yield represent yes um do you know since
you've been looking at these numbers
what was a typical uh 2022 election turn
out say for for the for all the states
do you have that information I I didn't
I didn't research that okay just as a
point of clarification the secretary of
state does actually have that report
online if anybody wishes to go look at
it it's quite fascinating New
Hampshire's always in the top
three representative Hamlet
I'm sorry representative ham
representative I apologize I'm going to
your colleag representative Brennan
thank you
um representative Wier thank you for
being here um I'm seeing a number of
claims in your testimony and I'm hearing
a number of claims in your testimony and
I'm wondering if you might be able to
site your sources so that I can do some
follow-up
research I think the uh the auditor
um I should have written her name down
had so many names in my mind lately but
anyway I think it's on voter integrity
and she's got the figures from 2022
she's a person that was arrested so
often in in the uh Nashwood Town Hall
she moved out of the state every
much okay um any other questions
representative Hamlet thank you Mr Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so could you just please
explain the the graph that you have on
the backs side of the page yes what U
what do those percentages stand
for basically what I wanted to show when
somebody say well how are we know that
the Voting is more than 100% well we
have all the census data and it goes by
towns and it goes by cities and it tells
us right there citizens 18 years and
over and that's will be in every s
report so that would be basically the
100% if everybody that was in that town
that was over 18 voted that would be
100% if the number exceeded
that then we have a few
phonies further questions represent oh
sorry yield represent Hamlet which qu
okay president of thank you for taking
my followup so but these percentages are
100% no no the important one is Citizens
18 years and over a million
35684 out of 3 something million 3.1
million I think we have in the state so
only 1,35 6684 are above the age of 18
now if you went and did this town by
town you would have the number in your
town that were in the census that were
over
18 okay if that number was
286 and you've got 300
ballots that would be questionable
you're having over 100% voting so you
would look at the census numers that
should be in your town and it would be
very unusual to even make 100% but to
exceed 100% And with the number of in in
Elizabeth
Todd's voting that were typically 25 to
30% same day
registrant which usually is highly
speculative those are the ones that in
2016 filled out affidavits and then when
they wrote a letter to that address no
one
there so okay representative
L go representative qua that's right
sorry I'm getting my it's getting late
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question representative I have
a question that relates to the wording
in the bill itself and it's on line
three that first sentence that starts in
any polling place with the moderator
reports a total ballot I'm reading that
sentence I'm not sure if I'm having a
reading comprehension problem or maybe
there's a word that doesn't belong there
in any polling place with the moderator
reports a total ballot count which
exceeds the number of registered
voters Etc including voters shall have
the election result negated does the
word in at the beginning of that
sentence maybe not belong there am I
what am I missing there am I am I just
reading that wrong well the negation of
election is the is the label of that
section of the law that would be added
but what is shall have what shall have
the election result negated I don't see
a subject for that sentence it's been a
long time since I diagrammed the
moderator where the moderator reports a
total ballot
count perhaps it's not the best
grammar am
I all right well that was my question I
mean I don't need it answered right this
minute yeah I can see where it's a
little confusing who would negate it
right who that's that's the vital thing
and I I kind of leave this to the
Secretary of State and and try to
empower him and have him looking at wow
this is a pretty high turnout not not
only that it was more than there were
people in the town well I understand
your your argument I just really being
fussy about that sentence and I'm not
sure it makes perfect sense as written
it's in your hands you'll have to excuse
the representative he's an engineer and
these things matter well they they do
matter they do matter of course they do
you that's why I love you um don't put
down
Engineers are you an engineer MIT oh
Lord um we'll have last question from
representative Lane he he knows better
than just to admit
it hand up too but um thank you Mr chair
um so I have a couple questions so there
may be a few follow-ups sorry um so this
information here is from a census is
that correct that's correct and the
census is done every 10 years correct
usually now they they even update it
fairly
regularly I think this one even had
okay see it has down there 2015 correct
so okay so if you're using that for now
or even the 2020 number for now aren't
disparities I would look for the latest
one and I think I think even the um one
of the Departments of the State updates
I know when I've working with the latest
numbers sometimes they bring me an
updated number
from uh either the administrative
Services as one of the other departments
in the state that do update um some of
the ones that are dependent on a
population a lawyer and an
engineer so you're so so you are willing
to take the vote away from an entire
Ward or town of people because the
numbers that we've gotten from a state
agency whether or not they've been
updated I don't know may be incorrect or
maybe people have moved into into the
town since those numbers have
been this will send a message to those
that pack us with phonies on the day of
registration that you're likely to have
it all negated I'm I'm I'm going to
offer some clarification here the bill
at no point references the census
numbers just so we're all on the same
page what the bill says because I think
we're getting off track and I'm going to
excuse representative wer after this but
so we're on the same page what the bill
does as read is it says if the total
number of votes I'm assuming cast is
larger than the total number of
registered voters including those that
registered on Election Day so if there
are more votes cast than there are
voters on the roles after same day
registration then the election is
negated I know we're talking a lot about
these census numbers but no nowhere does
the bill does the word census appear in
the bill the bill says registered voters
including those that registered on
Election Day so we're talking about an
election in which more ballots are cast
than there are registered voters a
including those who registered on
Election Day so with that I'm going to
let representative Wier go back to the
golden Halls of Finance um that'll be my
last C that I will yes we have one more
ahead thank you uh isn't the process of
a recount going to give us more
information about what happened if
there's a transposition
error or some other unusual situation
like say what happened in Windham we
find out more when we have a recount and
then we can fix those problems this
would keep us from being able to do that
right that's my concern well I mean
you'd start off with
saying we have
235 registered voters we have 250
ballots how could that
be
and you know even if you did a recount
235 then you would it might be worth it
to do that if you say we somehow we get
double counted
somewhere thank you representative wer
uh next up will be deputy secretary of
Hennessy
good afternoon my name is Aaron Hennessy
I'm the deputy secretary of state and
I'm here on behalf of the Secretary of
State's
office um I have a few comments on this
bill one um I would like the
clarification on the wording it
currently says at any polling place
where the moderator reports a total
ballot count um earlier today we had a
bill about um that um talked about our
ballot inventories and at the end of
most every uh polling location the count
of the ballots will exceed by far the
number of of Voters checking in or some
of all votes at that polling location so
if the intent is for cast ballots I
would like that clarified versus the
count of the ballots because the
moderator does have to report the count
of the ballots um according to 658 31
and 32 um the casting of the ballots the
cast ballot information is on different
forms so we would like a clarification
on what form this information would be
on whether it be the moderator
certificate the monitor's work sheet um
or some new form um I I do have similar
fears uh that were also um echoed in
this by committee members that um this
would disenfranchise voters um we have
308 polling locations in the state that
means that we have 308 different
moderators um and clerks and supervisors
of the checklists um that all work as a
team uh along with ballot clerks um
filling out forms um giving us
information and we always have a form
that has um incorrect information un
unintentionally um where they've written
the number backwards or they' added an
extra zero um and this um this bill
doesn't give any option for our office
to reach out to that polling location to
um fix any errors that were made
unintentionally okay and I assume you'll
be taking questions I'm happy to take
questions okay are there questions on
the committee representative
Bay thank you Mr chair so if uh there's
after the paperwork submitted to you and
there are more uh votes cast than than
the registered voters plus same day
registration is there a procedure a
written procedure as far as what
happens thank you for the question um
currently there's no no procedure in law
to find out to do anything with that um
what our office did recently um was
reviewed all the return information and
tried to follow up with the um polling
location moderator to find out um ask
questions
um most of the questions that we asked
had to do with ballots cast versus some
of all votes and uh the issue I talked
about earlier where the undervotes may
have been overstated because they were
turned into right-in votes but were
never um reconciled that way you didn't
take away an undervote for the new right
in vote that you've discovered um so the
sum of all votes would be more than the
ballots cast in that instance um
sometimes the moderators were able to
look at paperwork work that they had and
and realized oh yeah that was my issue
and corrected it um other times they may
have taped all of their paperwork inside
of The Ballot Box although we don't
recommend um that they seal up their
notes at the end of election night
sometimes it happens um and they are
unable to um confidently say what the
issue may have
been represent
wood thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um is the Secretary
of State Department aware item six here
says she found 22 polling places where
the number exceeds 100% is your office
aware of any example of a of a u place
where the number of cast ballots that's
what I'm reading here exceeds 100% of
the eligible
voters um thank you for the question not
to my knowledge uh I know that there was
a misprint in our red book for one town
um that did represent that um I really
hope we don't make that mistake again
but that was a misprint um yeah can I
follow up yeah I'm sorry you you sent me
on another uh another trip down memory
lane yeah go ahead yeah so what would be
the
problem with Implement if there was 100%
how could you say that there weren't
voters disenfranchised
in that process if you cannot if if you
have votes if your system comes up with
more votes than registered voters by we
we spent all this time collecting this
I'm stting to testify sorry thank you
thank you for correcting me he's trained
would you would you believe would you
believe no uh if I know all I'm saying
is how would that hurt if we had 100% it
problem so as an accountant I like to De
deal in details so so right now the bill
says ballot count which I see as a huge
issue
uh um so I think that for me to give an
opinion on what you've just said I would
just mean more details in the specifics
of the
situation thank you we let um secretary
Hennessy go unless there's another
pressing question yes representative
Brennan thank you thank you for taking
my question are you aware in the state
of New Hampshire of any instance any
evidence any legitimate evidence of
widespread voter
fraud thank you for the question um
there are instances but there's no
widespread
instances thank you thank you thank you
deputy secretary um next up will be uh
votes good afternoon uh chairman members
of the the committee my name is McKenzie
St Germain um I am the campaign director
for the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights which is a project of
America votes uh here today in
opposition to House Bill 1348 um wanted
to start off by saying we know that
there was not widespread voter fraud in
2016 there's no evidence of fraud in any
sort of New Hampshire elections um and
our current registration laws do require
that new registrants provide ID when
they register to vote for the first time
um and need to provide ID within 7 days
if they don't have it on Election Day
for their ballot to count so I think
that is worthwhile forone keeping in
mind I also just in the context of this
conversation was able to quickly pull up
some of the numbers from the Secretary
of State's website for 2016 there were
755,000 ballots cast there were 1,
7,42 people on the checklist and the
citizen voting age population according
to Census Data at that point was around
uh 1, 35,000 so some context of what the
state is providing for us in terms of
both ballots cast voters in the
checklist and citizen voting age
population this bill is incredibly
concerning um in terms of removing votes
wrongfully from uh the count because of
a mistake that could be made um if
someone you if uh voters who are
eligible voters cast their ballots we
should never be removing their votes
from the results I not aware of any case
in which there was actually data that
there were more ballots count or more
ballots cast than the number of people
who were registered to vote or who were
in the town um as deputy secretary
testified I know there were some
independent cases where numbers were
written down wrong on the form we should
absolutely make sure that those are
addressed and corrected in any place
where it seems that there are more
ballots cast than voters that is
absolutely an issue that we need to
figure out you know recounting doing a
um a recount a hand count diving into
what happened there that absolutely is
an issue we must remedy if it were to
happen however removing eligible voters
votes from the election is unacceptable
and not something uh that we should
allow to happen in our New Hampshire
elections okay will you piaying
questions sure are there questions
seeing none thank you thank you last up
to last up with the pink card is Olivia
Inc from open democracy um
representative anenberg you start
tossing that blue
sheet I wasn't planning to testify but
um Olivia zinc uh with open democracy um
I I want to speak on a couple of things
that have been said here in this
testimony I I had the pleasure of
serving on the voter confidence
committee and I traveled around the
state listening to testimony about uh
how we can improve voter confidence and
I think it's really important that we
think about how to improve voter
confidence um but when we look at the
you know line three and four on total
ballots counted at the end of the night
normally it's 10 or 11 or late after a
long day moderators are filling this out
and the total number of ballots count
includes blank ballots so you could have
blank appsente T ballots and you can
have blank regular ballots so the total
number of ballots and the secretary of
state is who decides how many ballots
are printed and sent to each community
and and I think they do a very good job
estimating but they're often times
there's leftover ballots sometimes towns
have to print more but I think that this
needs to be ballots cast online four
absolutely if you move forward but also
I think that this legislation
um I think we could do a better job
updating the moderators worksheet so
that the moderators are all reporting
the same things I have seen mistakes
where handwriting mistakes where a
moderator number is wrong in the total
number and when it a couple of days
later there's an updated list on the
Secretary of State's office with the
corrected moderator number so this I
have seen this happen where there's
number of of Voters but it's oftentimes
a mistake and it's reprinted two or
three days after the election um but I
would love to see a moderator's
worksheet written in plain English so
every moderator could understand it and
I would also love to see moderators
enter this information on like a form
and that there's not a somebody
interpreting the handwriting of the
moderator and putting it in a
spreadsheet um I think that would do a
lot more to increase voter confidence
than a bill like this happy to take
questions any questions seeing none
thank you there's no one else signed up
to speak uh with that I will close the
public hearing on House Bill
1348 uh there was no one signed up on
the blue sheet online there were seven
in support and 22 opposed that I'm
closing the
1348 I'm going to immediately open the
public hearing on House Bill
1381 relative to required training on
Election procedures I will recognize I
presenting yes thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee members for the
record my name is Robert W I have the
privilege of serving in
Hillsboro's County uh 13th District the
great town of
Hudson renowned in yester year for the
home of Benson's wild animal farm
so um
where so for thir uh for 1381
um we've heard um um Miss zinc just uh
made reference to the uh report on the
special committee on voter confidence uh
back from
2022 and that stated that public
confidence is high because elections are
administered at the local local level
according to State guidelines and so
efforts should be uh made to ensure that
proper training in these State
guidelines for elections um are
available to the uh local Personnel
conducting the elections secretary of
state currently offers training on the
election procedures and has repeatedly
reported to this fine committee that
election procedures training is often
poorly attended with less than 50% of
the communities
participating um that uh 2022 report on
voter confidence also made repeated
recommendations to require proper
training for the administration of
Elections at the local level and then um
last week we have heard um about issues
in the uh fine town of Windam as well as
in the uh Senate District race the
issues that were brought up with there
there and certainly some of those um uh
scores and um and uh large numbers of
Errors could have been reduced by
adequate
training so I you know this is this requ
request for training um in no way should
impune the many wonderful clerks and
moderators that we have um there are a
number of election officials in New
Hampshire who diligently performed their
job and handled their responsibilities
with great professionalism and integrity
and these individuals are probably in
the majority but they are not the
problem um as we saw from these forensic
audits that were conducted within the
last several years um there are clearly
some areas of great negligence and where
people have abdicated their
responsibilities our voters deserve more
and so this specific training
requirement in this proposed Bill
Endeavors to close that
Gap specifically um it and I don't I
don't think it the Secretary of State's
office will comment on this um but we've
already known that that training is
available and being provided so I don't
think we're by codifying it I don't
think we're putting an additional burden
on that off office but um I'll wait uh
the Secretary of State's office to
testify to that
um and so basically this just um adds
that this training should be documented
and that it should be required and that
um elsewhere where we already have um
Provisions for lack of training under
RSA
65977 that that would also be addressed
so um that's it and with that I am happy
to take any
questions questions from the committee
uh repres Vice chairman M excuse
me thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question one of the problems
I see here is with the Secretary of
State already
offering education is all the people are
volunteers including the moderator who
doesn't make that much and they have
jobs it might be difficult them to do
any training other than reading the
manual and like the added says you can
lead a horse to water but you can't make
him drink and so the same thing is
happening here and I don't see it
requiring
but what what if somebody doesn't go
what do you
do well well that's what uh provision
number four I believe addresses that if
if they fail to attend it's considered a
lack of training as already codified in
the
RSA so follow up yeah so what happens
then though they have a lack of training
but what does that do to the
um this doesn't provide for any
enforcement um but this this identifies
whether or not there's a problem in
terms of training and Doc documents
whether or not the training has been
completed and
um attended
to so um I've I just I want to actually
thank you um so I was was having lunch
with my parents today and my dad asked
me the four years you've been three
years doing this have you read the
entire section of RSA all the election
laws I said probably not all of them but
there's not much I'm missing uh this was
actually one of them so I just read it
while you were giving your testimony so
what happens is during lack when they
finding of lack of training um means
that the a Attorney General's office
will appoint a election moderator so my
understanding is is if you don't go to
the training then the Attorney General's
office would then basically see an over
or that's what I just read at
least I have a question for you did you
mean to say monitor monitor did I say
moderator I meant monitor excuse me
monitor so but anyways thank you for
that I didn't even know that section
existed and now I do um happy to provide
you that thrill because I had that I had
that same question representative Bo has
and I just went went got to reading uh
any other questions from the
committee representative
hamr thank you it's um would you believe
would you that I'm election official in
Manchester and to get our full pay of
thousands of dollars for working that
one
day um we have to attend a training and
work the election right so would you
believe that you had to attend training
yet I yes i' I've attended my own Town's
training practices I I think they're
very good um part of this though allows
for the Secretary of State to record the
training so um I can't speak for every
moderator but my moderator is certainly
very diligent he attends the training um
you know and then communicates that uh
the lessons learned to the group of
people group of volunteers that have uh
agreed to participate in the election
and he communicates that and trains them
very well this is meant again as I said
in one of my uh remarks on my Preamble
there this is not to impune the many
wonderful moderators and clerks who do
their job and do attend the training but
this is to really provide a mechanism
where you know they can attend online
training you know maybe I agree
that not everyone can be an uh at an
on-site training and conqueror and I'm
sure there are Regional offerings of
training but even so that may conflict
with other um commitments in in one's
life so the very fact that that training
could be recorded and then viewed at a
subsequent time as allowed in this
proposed bill I think expands the
opportunity or uh removes the
opportunities for lack of training if
you will so okay further questions from
the
committee uh representative
katab just wondering knowing that the
election schedule would place a new
moderator into position in March why
would we do this for the general ction
and not for the state primary why would
we if if we want to have training why
would it make sense to skip the
September primary and only give training
General prior to a state uh state
general election well that that may need
to be something that's amended
um so you're you're talking about line
18 I assume um correct where it talks
about that general election we may need
to write an amendment to expand that to
the appropriate races and so on thank
you okay further questions seeing none
thank you representative weie um next up
Hennessy thank you everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state I
think I need to sponsor this microphone
I've been up here so many times today
um first I want to thank the sponsor of
this bill for recognizing that in New
Hampshire we have wonderful elected uh
election officials uh who do a great job
with New Hampshire elections um this
bill um would put into law pretty much
everything we're already doing in our
office um we do a lot of uh inperson
around the state training I think we did
13 different in-person trainings U
before the presidential primary we
recognize that not everyone is able to
do in person training um and that we
have a very um diverse State
geographically where if you live up in
Coos County you're not going to go to a
training in Keen very easily when you
have a full-time job so we also offer um
online training um where we record um
pretty much PowerPoint slide type of
presentations um they're not as as good
as our in-person training because you
can't ask questions um but we also try
to do um and what we've done in the past
is a we record a online um uh session
where we do a presentation and then we
open it up for questions so you may not
if you're watching this recorded online
training at a later date you may not be
able to ask a question but you can
listen to all the other questions that
were asked um in the live online
training um but we do have many many
many different um recorded online
trainings is available for any election
official um if election officials do not
have access to this um they should reach
out to their Town Clerk or to our office
um we um spread this out to anyone who
has an email address in our Statewide
um and we are constantly expanding our
trainings um I do want to point out that
this um that there are a lot of
different elected election officials um
this bill does just speak to two groups
of them um we also have select board
members and we have supervisors of the
checklists that also do a great job in
our elections um but the the roles are
different between moderators and clerks
and supervisors and select people so um
just giving you that information the
only new part I see about this bill is
the lines 26 through
28 otherwise we do um we currently do
what the bill requires of
us questions from the
committee uh representative rafter have
heard from you today thank you thank you
for taking my question since this
requires attendance at training how
would you confirm that somebody has
attended if they don't attend in person
great question um you when we um have
our on and I don't remember the name of
the program but you have to request
access to the program with your email
address and then click the link that you
get to to do the online training um I'll
have to confirm if we can see if you've
Le left it but we can't tell if you put
it on and then you left the room and
didn't watch
it no one would ever do that no one
would ever do that come on Zoom meeting
we do have Vlogs of people who have
requested it um and watched it um and we
do have in when you come to our one of
our in-person trainings you sign
in further questions from the committee
representative
Bay thank you Mr
chair um you did mention that uh the
training the online training materials
get updated uh this is actually a
twofold question if you don't mind Mr
chair okay give the old two
parts how often are the training uh
online training materials
updated and uh when you say update what
type of update um is is done like and
and the spirit of my question is okay if
you have uh old PowerPoints before they
just update the PowerPoint or after
doing it so many years you now have a
master class uh type of training
material that's a great question we
don't have a master class but um if we
had more money and more people we could
create one um we I would say on average
again I've only been with the office for
about a year and a half now but on
average I would say we update them at
least every two years um if you if your
role as a ballot clerk
um um is ballot Clerk and it continues
to be ballot clerk there may not be any
new legislation that has changed like
right now we have write AV next to an
absentee voter in red pend if there were
legislation that would change that to
Red pen highlighted in yellow we would
update our presentation to make sure
that the ballot clerks knew that does
that make sense and then we also
do um any Law changes we do an update on
specifically any Law changes in
general questions representative prud
home O'Brien thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question are
there
any things materials uh that that these
election officials can walk away with
such as a certificate of having attended
or a badge I know that's probably not
the case but but something something
that they can show to the community
somehow just um that's a great question
I know uh because the clerk's
Association is an organized Association
and has regular meetings
that when we attend their annual meeting
uh the secretary does hand out um
recognition certificates for those that
have uh attended the most um trainings
and I don't know if there's a certain
threshold um for those certificates but
we don't have any um Rockstar badges or
anything like that for election
officials it might be a good idea okay
uh last question representative wood yes
thank you and thank you takeing my
question now um they mentioned here
about
about you sending an auditor or a
moderator
moderator if they do not uh for lack of
training I notice at some polls that
I've been at there have been uh somebody
from the state moderated what initiates
that is it random or is it is it some
problem that initiates the moderator
being the or inspector I'm not sure what
the word is you can help me thank you
thank you I think that you're referring
to 65 977 and it's a monitor an election
Monitor and it's it's a it's a formal
process where um your polling location
has been recognized that um you you did
something wrong um it could be I'm not
going to go into what it could be but um
we did have one um in this past election
I believe we may have had two or three
previously um I've been a monitor myself
twice
now F quick followup okay so this would
be consistent pretty much what you're
correct yes representative P Brian yes
uh thank you very much for uh letting me
ask another question I was really
interested in what representative HR
said about the um connection between
being paid as an ele election official
and her community of
Manchester uh to the training she has to
take the training it's a requirement uh
are you aware is of other communities
doing that is that a widespread practice
do you um what do you know about that
thank you thank you that's a great
question I am aware of other communities
that do require training um so a um I
think it's if you some communities can't
the clerk can't require that the
supervisors go to training but they can
require that the ballot clerks that they
hire go to training um to an extent um
further questions seeing none thank can
I Mr chair can I just clarify something
sure sir so um If This Were to go into
effect and there were to be several um
election election officials that did not
go to training um I can't project what
that would be but I can tell you that um
our current process we're extremely
strapped thin at um election time and if
it did require us to hire a bunch of um
election monitors who are experts in
election um which usually sometimes is
either someone from our office or
somebody who is a previous moderator um
it would require it it may require
additional Staffing um and additional
money you have to talk to representative
left got me on that one R thank you
thank
you that was a good one he's quick on
his feet y'all all right uh next up is
clerk good afternoon thank you for
hearing my
testimony
um I am Tina Guilford I am the to clerk
in
Derry uh I have no problem with training
I have no problem with required training
um I do have an issue um and I'm going
to start by turning your attention to
lines
123 and it says that the manual shall be
distributed free of charge to each
moderator Board of Selectmen city
council Board of Supervisors of the
checklist and to each town city and Ward
Clerk and that's because there are
sections in this manual this manual is
400 and some odd pages that address each
job
that these people are responsible
for but sadly go from line 26
down only the town award moderators and
clerks are being put on the hook and
that is not okay um so a moderator does
not register voters on Election Day
that's the job of the supervisors of the
checklist um the Selectmen have their
own jobs in my town they're Town
counselors but they still have their own
jobs and
responsibilities and it is more than
just handing out stickers although
that's what some people
think
um it is not right if you're going to
want people to attend training then
everybody should attend training um I
know for our poll
workers people working in the polls if
they don't attend
training they're not working on Election
Day um that's just how we do it in
Dair um if people want to be paid
they're paid if they want to volunteer
they volunteer and that's great um but
we do have our own training um a lot of
the training that we offer is a little
bit different than what secretary of
state offers because we have pull pads
so ballot clerking is something very
different in Dairy than it is in towns
that don't use pull pads um but we have
we have training for our assistant
moderators we have training for our
greeters we have we have training for
all our positions um and that's internal
training that we do at Town Hall uh we
run training sessions in the morning we
run them in the afternoon we run them at
night we run them on weekends um we make
sure that everybody's trained we had 130
pole workers on primary day we're
largest polling place in the state so we
have a lot of people and we try to do no
lines no traffic you know that's seems
to be the standard in Dairy no
traffic but it's a group effort and we
are all part of that
group it is not right to try to put even
more on just one or two particular
elected offices when they're all
responsible and everyone needs to do
their part and I will take any questions
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you um I have no one else signed
up to speak
right um so if we can get the blue sheet
going and online House Bill
1381 had 23 in support three opposed
zero neutral it is a blank blue sheet so
with that I will close the um public
hearing on House Bill 1381 and I will
open up our final public hearing House
Bill 1091 I will point out we are only
three minutes behind 12 bills three
minutes behind now we got that's the
real the real hero totally makes up for
my comment earlier totally now we
got if he can make election law run on
[Laughter]
anything we just got to read this and
then we have train engineer train that's
right I guess it could be e
and then we get to uh to end with my
favorite subject which everybody just
gets so excited about it is probably the
most interesting thing we handle
campaign
it
yeah
uh um okay it's late it's a little hot
in the room we've got campaign Finance
I'm excited you're excited
representative Lane is excited
representative Lane if you could turn
your microphone on and thank you for
introducing House Bill
1091 uh thank you Mr chair uh my name is
uh representative Connie Lane I'm from
here in conquered War I March District
16 and um this toome that I just handed
out to you is the report of the
subcommittee that was chaired by
representative qua and attended by rep
Ross myself representative mad and
representative Ward um over the summer
and we wrote this up and it the reason
we formed this
subcommittee was
because there's been much confusion
around our existing um campaign Finance
laws which are in chapter
6664 um and the attorney general and the
Secretary of State um are asked many
many many questions about those um
Provisions it's been amended hodg Podge
wise over the years over the last 20 25
years and um they approached us at one
point to help us clarify the law and so
that's why the subcommittee was formed
and our goals of the subcommittee are
set out um there are three of them and
they're on page one um of the report
that I just gave you it's to review view
the current campaign Finance laws as
embodied in
6684 make specific legislative uh
recommendations on the following uh
streamlining and improving the current
New Hampshire statutes in order to
balance the need for
transparency and and the need for trying
to run an election particularly those of
us in the house which are usually doing
it on our own and without staff um
reducing inconsistencies that exist in
the new Hampshire campaign Finance laws
and improving the clarity of current New
Hampshire campaign Finance
laws so I put together my notes and I
wrote the Bill that sub was submitted to
you um and have gone through it and I
already have some changes and I'm sure
all of you will I met I met with the
Secretary of State's office um for two
and a half hours yesterday and uh uh uh
and uh deputy secretary Hennessy and
Budge Fitch uh gave me a lot of notes
and stuff to to go forward on I'm
waiting to hear from the attorney
general with any changes and to make
sure that we addressed it because both
the Secretary of State and the Attorney
General came and talked to us and gave
us a laundry list of what they wanted us
or what they have problems with and what
they wanted to clear up so I tried to
address that in the bill but as you can
see it's fairly long and the devil is in
the det details because a lot of the
issues were that some of the terms
weren't defined well um and uh as you
all know I am a former attorney and so I
get a little wordy so that's the length
of the um some of the definitions are
rather long and I looked at other
statutes and so there's going to be some
more work on this so I would like to ask
the chair I mean we'll have the public
hearing today but I'd like ask the chair
if we can have another subcommittee so
that we can work on it further and take
everybody's comments take the comments
of whoever is going to speak today and I
want to get the notes and the comments
from the Attorney General's office so
that we can get a good bill in front of
you the next time we all meet and so
that we can um uh discuss it at that
point so that's really my I'll take
questions but I just didn't want to yeah
let me before we open up to questions I
want to thank representative Lane for
working so diligently on this and in
good faith
um I do think it it is a mess um so what
what this was we're going to handle this
bill a little differently than we handle
most bills um the goal here is to find
something that the entire committee the
entire committee can agree to to stream
as you said to streamline it to make it
consistent right we're not talking about
major policy changes we handle those
individually but making it everything
consistent across the board and more
uniform so we are going to form a
working group for this committee uh for
this bill whoever wants to dive into
this um is more than welcome to dive
into this it's going to get amended I
assure you it is going to get amended um
because as we cracked open that can of
worms a lot of things came out um and it
turns out if you change the law peace
meal by process over 40 years you get
things that don't all match so when
we're doing this public hearing um let's
let's be cognizant of that's where we're
going to head with the bill um so you
know if you have questions about intent
or that sort of stuff I think those are
fair uh but let's try to avoid getting
into like gross details um because we're
going to handle that as a committee
together
um yeah focus on the pretty details like
the fact that my name's on it no um
that's right so anyways with that most
importantly with that uh happy to have
representative take questions but I just
wanted the committee to be like in that
up all right well that was easy okay
whoa okay thank you all right uh next up
Hennessy thank you Mr chair I just want
to thank the subcommittee that worked on
this over the summertime I wasn't sure
when you decided not to have um
statutory subcommittees that it was
going to work out but I think this is
this committee did a great job of
showing up I think it was six times over
the summer to work on this um so I
appreciate that 664 is a very
complicated bill I mean complicated
chapter and and I appreciate the amount
of time that everyone put into trying to
fix this um I will try to attend any
subcommittees this um committee has if
not I may send out emails with our
recommended changes um I appreciate the
time that representative Lane spent with
our office yesterday to go through I
think we only got that through half of
her bill um so uh again I appreciate
that our our office's goal or at least
mine in particular would be that any
user of this particularly state
representatives state senators anyone
who has to file under this would not be
in our office asking because they got a
letter from the AG's office or they
didn't know how to do it um I just want
the um the requirements to be much more
simpler um bullet points ideally um so
that people can really understand what
they're supposed to report for
transparency
purposes questions from the
committee seeing none thank you deputy
secretary of state uh last pink card is
Olivia
zinc good afternoon um chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Olivia zinc executive
director for open democracy um and I am
a voter in Franklin and we're a
nonpartisan organization that works on
campaign Finance as well as improving
elections
and submitting um testimony and support
of 1091 as well as whatever Amendment um
I know is is coming forward um I think I
I just want to sort of thank
representative qua for leading the
committee the subcommittee uh
representative Lang Barry Ward and Mirad
for cont comp like six or seven hours I
sat through many of these hearings many
members of the public set through um
this but they took the time to read
through 64 line by line making
amendments um figuring out where the
confusing confusing parts of the
reporting is putting hours in to make
the law as clear as possible and I that
is a an amazing goal to do that in a
bipartisan fashion um and Clarity on
campaign Finance is critical for public
confidence in elected officials and
voters deserve the
transparency um I do want to make some
suggestions cuz that's what I do um so
on page two line 28 when we talk about
political advertisement I think it would
be important for that definition to be
also looped in with the definition of
comp communication and expenditures
because right now political
advertisement should be should
also um talk you know any expenditure
made on behalf of a candidate so
thinking about how to Loop those in so
that the disclos Ure requirements under
66414 apply to all political
advertisements so I would look at um the
definition of political
advertisement on page um three line
nine um the definition of expenditure I
know this committee looked at the
definition of expenditure a lot um and I
think um the intent here is is really to
make sure that there's a comprehensive
definition of what a political
expenditure an exp a campaign
expenditure is um including ads uh to
influence the words um but the the
problem with sort of only using the
magic words of vote for and vote against
um you also have to uh expand that to
include the express advocacy which is in
the definition of an
election um with I.E um the definition
of election arean communication but also
the functional equivalent of Express
advocacy and any communication promoting
supporting attacking or opposing
candidates or measures um so that
definition of exp expenditures could be
improved for clarification purposes um
on page
four um line five um independent
expenditures Miss can I pause your fast
these all these changes you're
suggesting are they in Rewritten
testimony no okay all right continue
then I know I need to know what
diligence what what diligence I needed
to take notes on thank you sorry they're
not uh sorry I I can write them out up
and email them if that would be helpful
yes um so page four line five um the
independent expenditures there's a great
uh handout on coordination laws um from
what should be independent of a
candidate expenditures and those that
are independent um so I think adding
language in that section around
coordination and what does mean to
coordinate um and what does it mean to
be independent it would be really
helpful in that section and then one
other minor suggestion is Page um six
line 13 um when we talk about
registration requirements and I think
the attorney general and Secretary of
State also spoke about this there's a
bunch of different triggers and
thresholds like if you're a candidate
you file if you hit a $500 threshold if
you're an independent expenditure you
file only after and expenditure has been
made so really making sure that these
registration
requirements um come into a
more easier to understand and clarify
and standardization of what those
committee registration thresholds are
and what the difference between one
committee
um representation and also like in Maine
for example they use this major purpose
to Define groups and I think that uh
looking at sort of the First Circuit
case law and what has been litigated
under campaign Finance might be helpful
when you look at what registration
requirements are needed and with that um
happy to take questions or also be a
resource if needed on um this important
bill questions representative Mirad
really appreciate all your suggestions
and if it were possible to to um to
convey them to the committee and and
Britain form I think that would that
would really be a help I will do that I
today okay um further questions from the
commit and and uh Miss s if you could
please give us those in writing because
that was a lot and I'm not even going to
understand half things I wrote down um
but it would be very helpful to have
those in writing um uh with that I have
no one else signed up on the pink
cards um online I thought this one was
going to go longer to be fair uh online
we are looking at 26 in support five
opposed um any on the blue we do have
stuff on the
blue two people signed up in person who
did not speak both supporting the bill
uh with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 1091 that does
conclude our public hearings for the day
um we do have executive session at 300
p.m. um so we will stand in recess until
pm.
sure
did representative Lane leave the room I
jeez
well
okay 3 o' going to open up the noticed
executive session for the house election
law committee and there's my form um
going to start off with the easy one um
rep going to open up the executive
session on house Bill
1442 um representative Lane is
motion okay I'm G I make a motion to um
itl there's a motion for any speeding to
legislate from House Bill 1442
representative ward has seconded that
motion is there discussion on the motion
role representative
bone
yes pruto home o Brian
yes quy yes anenberg yes Burnham yes
weary yes wood yes Osborne
yes katab yes Lane yes Ward yes clerk V
what like us to come back to you yes
please okay continue please continue
with the role we'll come back to
representative Mirad yes B yes Brennan
yes
rung
yes Howard yes Raptor yes and Barry
shair votes yes and how does
representative Hamlet
vote Yes okay and with that uh House
Bill 1442 will be reported out as in
expedient to legislate 20 to Z um
representative oh can I have a motion
for the consent calendar I forgot to do
that I want this moved to consent
calendar any objection hearing none
thank you it's on to consent calendar um
represent Lane can someone from your
caucus handle the committee report it
should be
short you right um okay with that I will
close the executive session on House
Bill
1442 and uh now we can see where the
votes uh let's let's knock another one
out going to open up the H the executive
session for House Bill 11:19 and
immediately recess it um so click click
um House Bill 1119 is recessed
um now we will move
to a chance I'm all confused so can you
not read my mind you don't know the
first one was seconded by uh the first
one was a motion by representative Lane
it was seconded by representative
Ward and then House Bill 1119 was opened
and shut it will be noticed for next
Tuesday just as an FYI that will there
will be no more extensions on that um it
um okay oh wait a
minute there's no numbers on these oh
no well I'll tell you what next up is
going to be
oh okay so this one was open and close
that no that one was itl
20 this that's itl
20 1426 we're not even doing um because
that was a that was a mistake that one's
already been that one's already been
that was 101 that was a very nice speech
by myself if I may say um that was by
that was the conversation I had with I
was like are are you sure you've done
um so we'll open up 1577 next give the
clerk a second um 1577 FN relative to
digital images of ballots
representative wey is recognized for a
motion I'd like to make a motion uh
ought to pass so that we can hear an
amendment is there a second to the
motion representative Burnham seconds
are there any amendments yes there yes
there is thank you Mr chair
representative weary is recognized to
introduce an amendment all right so um
you have in front of you uh uh Amendment
so you say uh so representative weary
motions to
2024-25
95h we are on discussion on the
amendment is there any discussion on the
amendment I could introduce you
represent you are you are recognized
representative we to speak to your
motion so uh the original sponsor um and
I
uh uh went through and identified
different things from the testimony
original sponsor did most of the work
just let me give credit where credit is
due and identified the different um
concerns that were raised during
testimony addressed those as well as I
believe there was one um concern raised
by the Secretary of State's office and
that was also addressed so there are
some um about about five changes total
um to this um compared to the original
bill um and I apologize I do not have
with me the email that uh where I could
tell you exactly what those changes are
but
um um basically they did address the
concerns that were raised by the
committee during the original
testimony further discussion on the
amendment questions comments
concerns okay hearing none the clerk
2024-the
wood yes Osborne yes katab yes Lane yes
Ward yes clerk vot yes
oops
Hamlet yes Mirad yes B yes Brennan yes
rung yes Howard yes rapor
yes
chair 20 yep and the chair votes yes oh
chair it's okay you can assume my votes
as long as you assume it correctly we're
fine
um 20 uh with that Amendment 2024 59h is
adopted 20 to Z the motion is now on a
to pass as amended House Bill 1577 is
there discussion on the bill as
amended hearing none the clerk will call
what
R oh was he motion okay isone want to
make a motion of a to pass as amended
representative wey makes the motion
representative Burnham are you seconding
yes I'm second thank you we're now on
discussion as the bill is amended is
there any discussion on the bill is
amended hearing none the clerk when she
is ready we'll call the role
representative boam yes prud home Brian
yes quy yes anenberg yes Burnham yes
weary yes wood yes Osborne yes katab yes
Lane
no Ward nope clerk votes no Hamlet no
mad no b no Brennan no rung no Howard no
raor no and Barry the clerk votes yes
with that the op to pass as amended
motion fails representative Lane is
recognized to make another motion I move
to itl is there a I'm sorry I
to itl the bill um there representative
Lanes made a motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1577
representative Mirad seconds that motion
is there any discussion on the motion of
been expedient to legislate seeing none
the clerk will call the
role
B
no prud home Brian no quy
no anenberg no vernham no weary no wood
no Osborne no katab no Lane yes Ward yes
clerk votes yes Hamlet yes Mirad yes B
yes Brennan yes rung yes Howard yes
Raptor yes and Barry no um and with that
the most inexpedient to legislate fails
House Bill 1577 will be reported out
without recommendation with that I'll be
closing the executive session on House
Bill
1577 and opening up the um
the the executive session on House Bill
1147 relative to permissible campaign
contributions by business organization
and labor unions um representative Lane
is recognized for a
motion I move out to pass oh yeah out to
pass y you're out yeah that's what I
figured um representative Hamlet would
like to amend y so I second it yeah we
have second is there an amendment yes I
have an amendment and I haven't passed
it out yet okay would you like to
distribute the amendment then we'll make
Amendment what bill we are on
okay thank you here take all those thank
yet
no
the motion the motion is ought to pass
and then I believe there's about to be a
second motion representative Hamlet
you're recognized to make a motion thank
you Mr chair I move ought to pass on
amendment number
2024 -06 38h is there a second a second
representative Lane representative Lane
seconds we are now on discussion of
amendment 202 24-0 63h does every
Committee Member have the
amendment have the amendment is there
discussion on the amendment
representative l l excuse me
representative Hamlet is recognized
thank you so this amendment is strictly
a housekeeping Amendment um the original
Bill used references to rsas that were
in the old election manual and so the
amendment just updates them to the
purple election law manual which is uh
20242 25 laws and so for example there's
a few little um on line
two uh it says amend RSA 664 colon 4
Roman numeral 3 was changed to Roman
numeral 2 on line three the it was also
changed to Roman numeral 2 on line 11 it
was also changed to read uh Roman
numeral 2 and then on line 16 the RSA
would change to read 664 colon 4 Roman
numeral
one thank you is there further
discussion on the Amendments seeing none
um I will I will say we have enjoyed a
very nice courtesy in this Committee of
allowing amendments in good faith so I
would encourage both sides to vote for
this irrespective of
your of your final vote um we've
operated that way it doesn't mean it's
your vote to do with as you see fit but
I would like to keep the committee
moving forward so I will be voting yes
on the
amendment and the clerk will call the
roong representative bam
yes pruto home O Brien yes quy yes
eckenberg yes Burnham yes weary yes wood
yes Osborne yes katab yes Lane yes
Ward yes CL votes yes Hamlet yes
Mirad Bay yes Brennan yes rung yes
Howard yes raor yes and Barry chair
votes yes and with that Amendment 2024
03h is adopted 20 to Z representative
Hamlet is recognize for a new
motion so I recommend a to pass on house
Bill 1147 as amended as amended we have
a motion for otpa on House Bill uh 1147
is there a second representative Mirad
seconds we're now in discussion as the
bill as amended is there discussion on
the bill is amended seeing none the
role representative bam no P Brian no
qua no eckenberg no
Burnham no weary no wood no Osborne no
kab no Lane yes Ward yes clerk V yes
Hamlet yes Mirad yes B yes Brennan yes
rung yes Howard yes rafter yes and the
clerk uh the chairman the chair votes no
with that the motion of oop pass as
Amendment fails representative weary is
recognized to make a motion I'd like to
make a motion to itl the bill there's a
motion of any expedient to legislate
from representative wey is there a
second I'll second representative
Burnham seconds we're now on discussion
as the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1147 is there
any discussion hearing no discussion the
role
representative boam
yes prudo hom Brian yes quy yes
eckenberg yes Burnham yes weary yes wood
yes
Osborne yes katab
yes Lane no
Ward
no um clerk vs no Hamlet no Mirad may I
just ask which bill this is
that classic uh representative Mirad we
are on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on house B 1147 and the
majority of your caucus appears to be
voting
no
no okay
no Brennan no rang no Heath no
Howard Raptor no and bar and the chair
will vote Yes and with that the motion
of in speed to legislate fails House
Bill 1147 will be reported out without
recommendation I will be closing the
executive session on House Bill 1147 and
opening the executive session on House
Bill
1074 um House Bill
1074 you I'll make okay representative
Lane is recognized for a motion um I
want to make a motion a to pass um but
and I'm expecting an amendment which is
I don't know where it is would you like
to withdraw your motion allow me to
recess the bill until the we'll drop it
to the end I'll happily do that I am
more than happy represent L is
withdrawing her a motion I'm recessing
the executive session on House Bill 1074
we will vote on this bill today but
we're going to give the member a
courtesy of getting the amendment in um
going to open up the H um the executive
session House Bill
1369 um
representative katab is recognized for a
motion on House Bill
1369 I move ought to pass is there a
second I second that representative Pam
O'Brien seconds the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 1369 is there any
discussion on the
bill hearing none the clerk will call
the role okay
OTP representative bow
yes PR home o'ban yes quy yes ekenberg
yes Burnham yes weary yes wood yes
Osborne yes katab yes Lane no
Ward no clerk votes no Hamlet no mad
no b
no brenon
no rung no Howard no Raptor no and Barry
shair votes yes with that the motion of
a to pass fails representative Lane is
recognized for another
motion I wonder what would it all
be I was just wondering myself um should
we make the motion to ought to pass and
then I go out no no we're on 1369 we
just voted on ought to pass if you'd
like to make the motion of ought to pass
I assure you many members of my caucus
will
be but I I was expecting you to make an
inexpedient to legislate
motion motion to it we have a motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1369 representative Brenan seconds the
motion we're now on discussion of the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1369 is there any discussion
on House Bill
1369 hearing none the clerk will call
the role for the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
okay representative bam
no P home O'Brien no qua no anenberg no
Burnham no no weary no wood no Osborne
no katab no Lane yes Ward yes clerk vote
Yes Hamlet yes
mad yes B yes Brennan yes rung yes
Howard yes rafter yes and the chair
chair votes no and with that the motion
of a to pass I mean in expedience to
legislate on the house bill 1369 fails
uh the the bill we reported out yes I
have a motion uh I move uh interim
study okay there a motion of inter room
second representative Hamlet seconds it
seconds is there discussion on the
motion yeah so as we had heard in the
Bill hearing the Secretary of State's
office had suggested six years and
there's still uh debate amongst the
Democratic committee or caucus uh over
how we want to proceed with this bill uh
I think it would be good to have
additional information looking at
exactly uh how many voters are purged
for that four-year period versus the
six-year period so that we can make the
best decision possible moving forward
thank
you okay um so further discussion on the
representative Mirad I'd be curious to
know whether members of your caucus
might be interested in participating in
that uh study um I I can tell you this I
have thought about this bill um I was
actually thanking the sponsor for it
earlier
um every 10 years we purge out 25% of
our
voters it creates a lot of
it creates a lot of anxiety when that
happens um on both sides of the aisle um
people that want the voter roles to
remain unchanged basically forever and
those who want to do like daily purchase
um I think four years and every four
years looking back four years is an
appropriate Middle Ground if if I was
the the governor um or dictator or
whatever I got to pick um it would be
every year looking back five years um so
I think 44 is probably where our caucus
is going to end up in general um I don't
see the need to study this honestly so
I'll be voting against the motion of V
to study I think we can have this fight
on the floor and I look forward to
it yes representative weing yeah there
there's also a Senate Bill similar
nature uh I don't know um apparently the
testimony changed to five
years um for the Senate but uh so we
will have another opportunity to look at
this as well when we review the Senate
bill I we never know what the mysteries
of the other wall will do true
representative
vernham thank you um I just wanted to
remind the committee that also we heard
from the uh representative the clerk's
Association who was for the four years
uh those are people that he's
representing those who are actually
dealing with this on a day-to-day year
toe and he really liked this the four
years so I support it and I will point
out that every four years the way the
schedule set up will always include a
presidential election which are high
just High turnout um so the the uh the
question that I proposition when it
comes to these voter roll purges which
have historically been used um by Bad
actors I don't believe this is a bad
actor Bill um is you know if somebody
goes four years without voting you know
why is it okay to take them off every 10
years but it's not okay to do it every
four years like it just doesn't the
logic doesn't line up if you can do it
every every 10 years why can't you do it
every four years so the way this sets up
it always have a presidential election
those are high turnouts in the high 70s
so I'll be voting against the motion of
interm study because as you can probably
tell we I'm already if it was up to me
like said it was me to be every year
looking back five years so we've already
we've already come off of I think where
we would like to be representative
Lane yes I think in light of the
discussion I would ask representative
Heath whether he wanted to withdraw his
motion yeah that that's fine I'll
withdraw thank
you the motion is withdrawn I appreciate
the representative withdrawing his
motion with that um House Bill 1369 will
be reported out without
recommendation representative Lane have
you received your amendment to House
Bill 1074 look we did it look at this
some say best chair ever some say some
say some
say all right uh we're going to open up
reopen up the executive session on House
Bill uh we've closed 1369 gabble gabble
gabble um and um we're going to open up
the public the executive session on
House Bill
1074 representative Lane is recognized
for a motion okay um is the has my
motion for a to pass already you
withdrew it okay so we're REM make a
motion for ought to pass and is there a
second for the motion of ought to pass
there I second representative H second
is there any any amendments wish any
members wish to introduce yes
representative Lane is recognized yes
coming around to you if you haven't
already gotten it is an amendment to the
bill it's uh number
30h and basically this bill we so you're
moving the amendment I'm moving the
amendment next representative Lane moves
amendment 20240 63h is there a
second representative Ward seconds we
are now on discussion of amendment 20240
63h to House Bill
1074 representative Lane is recognized
thank you this like the other one is a
housekeeping bill um and like the other
one the uh the wrong uh Roman numeral
was used in line uh lines eight all the
way through the bill anytime that uh
statute was referenced so it's been
changed to Roman numeral 4 and that's
there have been no substantive changes
those were the only changes how dare you
um any discussion on the
amendment representative
wey uh just um after the wonderful
public hearing earlier on House Bill
1091 which completely
revamps uh RS say
um I just um I wonder if this becomes
out of context I guess
um it could um we have to pass they have
they they basically look at what we pass
and they reassemble it um so you know it
depends on what we passed last so if
House Bill 1091 came out later it would
override what we did here um but there's
no guarantees we handle it one piece at
a time but as I said earlier
uh revisions are how
664 got to its current shape um that's
not a statement about this one in
particular but it's just that's how it
happens so we're on disc but it's a
great question we're on discussion of
the amendment 2024 H 063
20240 63h for house built in 74 Is there
further discussion on the
amendment seeing none the clerk will
call the role on House Bill 10 uh House
Bill 2024 house Amendment 2024 063 to
1074 representative B yes hero home
O'Brien yes quy yes eckenberg yes
Burnham yes weary yes wood yes Osborne
yes katab yes Lane yes Ward yes clerb
Jess Hamlet yes Mirad yes Bay
yes Brennan yes rung yes rafter oh
Howard yes rafter yes and the chair
chair votes yes and with that Amendment
06h is adopted to House Bill 1074
representative Lane is recognized for a
new
motion I think I'm going to get this one
right I'd like to ought to pass as
amended is there a
second we have a second so we are on the
motion of ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 1074 with amendment 20240 63h
amended hearing none the clerk will call
the
role representative bone no prud Brian
no qua no Berg no Burnham no weary no
wood no Osborne no katab no Lane yes
Ward yes clerk vote Yes hamblet Yes
Mirad yes Bay yes Brennan yes rung yes
Howard yes rafter yes and the chair CH
chair votes no with that the motion of a
to pass Amendment fails representative
weary is recognized for a new motion I'd
like to make a motion of an inexpedient
to legislate there's a motion of ined to
legislate on House Bill 1074
representative Burnham seconds second
with that we're on discussion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1074 is there any discussion on the bill
hearing none the clerk will call the
role on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1074 okay represent bam
yes prudo home Brian yes quy yes
anenberg yes Burnham yes weary yes wood
yes Osborne yes katab yes Lane no Ward
no clerk vots no Hamet no Mirad no Bay
no Brennan no
rung
no Howard no raor no and the clerk I
mean the chair chair votes yes with that
the motion of any speech legislate fails
House Bill 1074 will be reported out of
committee without recommendation um uh
that's going to close the executive
session on House Bill 1074 that
concludes our executive session today if
you have a committee report if you have
a committee report I am supposed to get
it to from you before you leave but we
are adults so just get it to me tonight
um especially if you have the committee
report
on um I believe 1577 was the early Bill
correct um yes it was so the committee
report for 1577 I need that tonight
because I have to have it to them
tomorrow by noon um so and I have to
review it so with that uh thank you guys
we did 12 bills and hearing and five in
exec and I will see you guys next
Tuesday and they'll be our last 10 bills
guys